[Music]
oh i forgot about ohio yeah
i didn't
i didn't
that's my last stand that's why we're
jammed that's why we're fucked because
you leave wednesday cincinnati ohio well
because we have to get you in to do that
goddamn show okay
so cincinnati ohio no leave all that in
i want cincinnati to know really off
camera how these conversations go we i'm
trying so hard to get to cincinnati like
desperately going in the day before yeah
yeah i that's unheard of unheard of
not like the night before you get this
like the full day before there's like 76
connections in order to get to
cincinnati we may not have a podcast the
following week because she has to be in
cincinnati
so if you have a problem with that call
the taft no but by the way last time i
missed the flight i mean yeah i no the
flight was delayed which means that the
connection was missed right somewhere
else so i sat in the uh
lax uh you know those restaurants that
only divorce people sit at
with their luggage like rock and brews
totally i was sitting there like
everyone when you sit in the airport
restaurants like having a market at like
8 30. but i think there's like a fuck
culture or something because no
i hope that's a fuck culture because
there's a lot of like
so you're stranded yeah
that's your old man you like your vibe
everyone feels comfortable talking to
everyone if you're alone in a like a
airport bar at that time
because everyone no one has good news
nothing good true that's true no
yes nothing to celebrate in there for
good reason right i once pretended to
look at my dead phone for like an hour
at um
like um at a
like a what is t wolfgang puck to go
yeah and they got with a guy with a
pinky ring kept talking to me and i was
like um
september 8th i and 7th i will be
here's the thing i'm performing in
cincinnati ohio the 8th i will be in
cincinnati the 7th
god will from your mouth to god what am
i doing that night
i couldn't tell yeah chili party what
are we doing are we doing fentanyl
actually we aren't doing anything
i don't know what airport i'll be
stranded in on the 8th but let's see i
will definitely be in cincinnati ohio
tap theater september 8th with a brand
new hour of material um september 9th
i'll be in philadelphia pennsylvania at
the miller theater and the ru garbage
guys are going to be opening the show
which is very very cool um if you
haven't listened to the ru garbage
podcast your garbage
september 10th i'll be in richmond uh
virginia at the national september 24th
i'll be in charlottesville virginia
paramount theater and i'm gonna take a
little trip home to virginia i'm gonna
go to roanoke for a couple days country
roads i know take me home um okay so
today is a very exciting day this is an
episode that is our good for you
university episode um uh i just like
calling them that i like that when it's
someone like fancy yeah yeah and uh it's
just i'm gonna be like serious and
reverent and um uh and this is by far
the least i've ever heard you
talk
byron allen who is the guest on the show
today is truly the only person i respect
the only person that i actually we all
just were in here like this yeah that's
with our mouths open a game
it he is my hero in many ways um i will
explain who byron allen is shortly even
though you'll know him in your you know
implicit memories or hippocampus anyway
like you definitely know who he is he's
a media tycoon he's brilliant he is my
mentor and like hero
he fixed my credit when i was 22 he gave
me not my first job but my definitely my
first stand-up appearance on television
taught me how the business worked in in
the in the most pivotal moments of my
career the biggest epiphanies i've had
were because of him i can trace back
everything i have to kind of like the
ways he's inspired me the conversations
we've had the things he's done for me et
cetera et cetera i love him so much um
so byron allen started as a comedian he
was the youngest comedian ever to be on
the tonight show um he has built a media
empire that is truly would take the
amount of time the podcast is to explain
uh all of his credits um uh his media
group owns 36 network affiliate
broadcast tv stations uh he produces
distributes sells advertising for 68
television programs it's one of the
largest independent producers
distributors of first one runs
syndicated television programming for
broadcast television stations in history
bought the weather channel in cash by
the way uh and planned for a 2022 launch
which just just started and the way that
what he's doing with the weather channel
is really
fascinating um uh and what he has to say
about science and uh the weather or lack
thereof um
byron allen uh is also going to um he's
such a brilliant innovator entrepreneur
businessman creative so not only did he
uh his career did he build the uh
opportunity to be able to purchase the
weather channel the reason he did it is
incredibly important and he also is
about to debut the weather channel and
espanol so no one had ever done that
like he just does shit no one ever does
or no one thinks to do because they
think someone else already did it and
that is such a big um missed opportunity
for so many people when you're like i'm
sure someone's done that whether it's a
joke whether it's a a business whether
it's an idea whether it's so many things
and like we've talked about this before
and sometimes other people are doing
things but right but it's kind of
whoever does it first right or fastest
also do you know what i mean so i think
there's so many ways down the gap
there's so many ways that we
find ways to talk ourselves out of giant
goals and this is a man that had the
most astronomical goals and i think not
only did he have the incredible work
ethic and the passion and you know
intelligence to execute it etc and talks
about positive addictions of like you
know but also
he i'm obsessed with um
the idea that set your goals impossibly
high because that's where you have the
least amount of competition yeah i'm
saying like no one else at least you're
not dealing with competition if you said
it with like i want to buy the weather
channel i want to put it like there's
but then you also go like that's such a
big goal uh how would i ever achieve
that but the good news is everyone else
is discouraged too
so if you just have like an inch more
confidence or an inch more work ethic or
like an inch more whatever obsessive
obsession or passion or fear or whatever
drives you like he's the best example of
that yeah you know he is
such a genius such a genius but also
he inspires me because he put the work
in too because if someone is just like a
genius i'm like i can't do learn that
right yeah right i don't i can't learn i
don't know lex friedman or i'm like i
don't right you know how to code robots
right that's never gonna no matter how
hard i work he is um a genius but also
doesn't act like he puts the work in as
if he's not yeah right what i'm saying
yeah he's a genius at work exactly yeah
the way that he runs his business is
fascinating you know it really blew my
mind just the idea of like you know
the sale the his sales people right you
know and the way that he treats them the
way that the their the philosophy of the
company i'll shut up but enjoy it um
also real quick i am doing clubs uh in
the fall
because i club you doing the i club you
tour october uh it's mostly around
california so just go on my website i
don't want to bother everybody else it's
just me working out my new hour around
uh southern northern california so uh
sarah silverman.com for dates love you
guys enjoy and we're doing a live show
oh yeah live show let me just cut to the
chase here
it's my birthday
i'm doing mushrooms
yeah i need to positive grace is not
doing mushrooms she's doing more
mushrooms
she'll be doing an addition i'm doing a
dose if everybody else is micro dosing
i'm just going to be on drugs
we're unclear about your tolerance
so i can't wait to figure it out on a
live stream so on the live show cut the
shit we're just doing mushrooms and you
guys uh get to decide how that goes for
me psychologically choose your own
adventure if you will so send birthday
videos um basically i want you guys to
curate the content that we watch uh
while i'm on mushrooms questioning my
we don't know purpose in life okay so
send those videos to good for you fans
at gmail.com buy tickets uh to the live
show september 6 at 6 00 p.m
pacific standard time
um we will put the website about
mushrooms write this website
momento
good for you so get your tickets at
moment dot co slash good for you send us
birthday video message we'll play the
best ones on the pod good for you fans
at gmail.com
is there a link tree
is this something maybe for your
birthday should we put this in my bio
it's awesome i think it's it's in your
mind the ig of my bio okay because i
don't i just read that i'm looking at
that website and i don't know what it is
you can do it we can do it dot co dot
yeah yeah
and that's not a typo i checked it no
it's real so there's a dot co now yeah
yeah do you know what dot com stands for
computers that's great
who's right for audio i thought that too
it's commerce it's computer
no one would be proud
it's like coordinates
so am i the smartest person
dot computer
this com stands for uh compassion
i think compassion
is compulsive
[Laughter]
compatible
the internet is for me
i was so sure it was
computer gotta be you said it's the same
way i said i was like computer that's
how i say every fact regardless of
whether i know
like whoever asked me it was like you're
dumb like why i don't even have time to
answer this like
you're dumb it's computer
medicine that's a no-brainer so as soon
as you realize it's commerce you're like
it would never be computer
especially because you can go on on your
phone but websites were invented before
you could do that on your phone i know
it's it's just so funny because i'm
right
i don't care
get to take you to the live show for
more of this kind of titillating
discovery
okay by the way just grace not knowing
something it's just really it's a big
day for me just let me have this
that was your birthday because we just
really it's just your gift
enjoy the great uh the legendary byron
[Music]
i'm not gonna ask you questions other
people have asked you that's fine you uh
your episode of the breakfast club i'm
sure you know yes is iconic oh i didn't
know that but yes it is like iconic and
it is so if everyone who wants to hear
byron's story if you don't know all the
granular elements listen to charlotte
means the breakfast club also your marc
maron is wonderful i don't want you to i
don't want to ask i never want to ask
questions that other people ask and i
think you might appreciate this because
you know the way that people consume
podcasts now if they're gonna watch it
on youtube is like they're probably in a
wormhole on the person you know and then
there's all these suggested videos on
the side so if i go i want to learn
about byron allen then i'm going to see
all these youtube videos and it's
everyone asking the same question really
you're brilliant this is why she's so
smart she's a superstar
she really is are we recording now we
are recording yeah
when i did his interview he said to me
he goes you are the most successful guy
i've ever been interviewed and i went
you do know you had president obama on
i'm just a comic hanging out with you in
a garage come on man
let's put it in perspective i love mark
when he says i was like what i'm gonna
bite my tongue
are you telling me that running the
white house is a successful business oh
okay
that actually kind of brings me to
something that i feel like we could
start on sure what does hollywood keep
getting wrong over and over and over
again a lesson they will not learn
whether it's overpaying for stars that
aren't going to give you your money back
whether it's giving too much money to
people that don't have enough experience
etc hollywood's the last to know
hollywood doesn't know anything
they really don't which i think
comedians we're so unique we're unique
because we're the ones who actually have
to stand on stage
and live or die pay our rent feed
ourselves based on going directly to the
consumer and getting a reaction every
five seconds
no one else has that training
no one else else has that software no
one else has to put themselves through
years and years of standing in a club
two and three times a night in front of
an audience and understanding
what is the psychology of the human
being and how do you connect
we are so connected to other people and
how they're wired and how they think
better than anybody which is why i think
it's not a coincidence that we're very
successful talk show hosts
podcasters sitcom stars movie stars game
show hosts because we are so in the
moment and we understand that american
psyche better than anybody that human
psyche better than anybody because
nobody else has gone through our
training you go spend 10 years 20 years
30 years standing in front of a live
audience a microphone in a spotlight and
getting a reaction every five or six
seconds nobody comes close everybody
else is a distant second after that kind
of interaction and training it's the
best training in the world and you can
apply that training to anything you can
apply that training to
being a showrunner creating a sitcom
creating a game show
business
business the same skills that i have
developed as a stand-up comedian i've
used in business
business my openness my frankness
you might have to be trustworthy you
know as comedians we have to be
vulnerable we have to be very honest you
have to be uh you have to be very strong
in your communication like you go into
corporate america everybody's just so
scared and charts and grabs i will be in
a meeting i'll say that sucks
okay that corporate america is not used
to that like you know when i when i talk
to my lenders i i say to them you should
give me a standing ovation nobody says
that to their lender it's charts and
graphs and flows i'm open i'm honest and
that and with business that's key you
know using humor the power of humor and
explaining like hey this is a better way
to do it hey this is something i mean am
i sales people
i have a reputation i have 2 300
employees
and i had somebody i just hired and they
said to a salesperson i love hiring
sales people because i love sales people
she said to me she goes
you have a reputation of being
very tough
tough in terms of you can't get anything
by you right right you will call it on
the spot like you're unfiltered and you
don't care like you're just like you
caught but that's what a comedian does
nothing gets past you a committee we
call it on the spot
right she goes but you also have a
reputation of being the best boss in the
world
you have a reputation for paying better
than anybody and i said yeah because i
value you
i value you
more than anybody and the best way i can
show you is through compensation so if
you think there's somebody out there
that will pay you more let me know they
never beat me
and you understand what makes people
happy as comics we know and also i
always say to people when they go oh
we're getting all these hr complaints
about words we're saying and
uncomfortable i go try paying your
employees a little more and see if they
still complain about the words you're
saying that's exactly right see what
happens that's exactly right you know if
they're happy if there's a culture where
they feel inclusive like you know i
didn't grow up in a corporation i grew
up in comedy clubs and it's a community
and it's inclusive i have people in our
meetings our management meetings that
have nothing to do with that particular
division like if you know if i'm i i
bought the weather channel in 2018.
and the dave mitzi's memorial oh that's
right the day of mitzi shores memorial
that's right that's right i love her i
love her i love her so i had you know i
i'll have people from broadcast
television stations sit in or people
from syndication or people from our
digital division because i want
everybody to know everything i want i
like being 110 percent transparent you
know i want you to know everything about
this company uh me our mission there
like there are no secrets people know
what we're working on like and i mean to
the point where it's almost it's uh it's
too much like there are no secrets at
our company you know i just straight up
just lay it like we're going after that
we're gonna buy that company we're gonna
do this we're gonna hire this person and
it's amazing it doesn't leak out but
that's part of the trust
but i say okay you're part of this
family you know you are a part of this
family you're not employee number 2300
now what really proved that is when we
had the pandemic when we had the
pandemic i didn't lay off anybody wow
incredible i didn't lay off one person
not one person eric petakovsky sitting
here is that true eric absolutely not
one person so you know the writers on
at the game show for months everybody
and so what happened was all these big
corporations laid off 20 30 40 of their
workforce i said no i said we are a
family and i this is i need i don't want
to go through a pandemic and then have
you worry about your paycheck and your
next meal
so the one thing you will know about me
is that when the chips are down i got
you i got you i'm gonna take care of you
and i'm always gonna take care of you
and you take care of this company
because if you take care of this company
you're taking care of people who are
also leaning in and taking care of you
okay so it's not about me it's about we
and no one's gonna win a championship
approaching it as a me you have to
always approach it as a as a wii
and you're not employee number 2300 you
are a part of a corporate family and a
corporate culture culture that culture
is really clear we're not here just
building a media company we're here
building a media company to help
effectuate change for the greater good
it's easy to make money
it's easy to make a lot of money anybody
could make money for crying out loud
you're in america this is america we
print money literally every day
onlyfans.com
no excuses no excuses yeah 80 trillion
dollars floating around out there okay
if you are smart hard-working and you
have a way to get someone a nice return
on their capital they're gonna lean in
and listen
and you that's what i want people to
know and something that you are in in
case y'all haven't noticed we're talking
to my hero byron allen gave me my first
job i mean eric peterowski i've dropped
off a vhs tape
and where was it in our office in
century city in century city was this 20
years ago 18 years ago it must have been
18 years ago it was 15 and a half okay
it just started and you came in
and you had a vhs tape vhs wow and a
backpack she came to century city which
is a
hassle for a comic so she came up to the
office yeah it came out i dropped it off
i remember yep i watched it i'm like
this is it byron changed my life lines
you got the jokes you changed my life
you gave me advice i don't even think
you probably remember giving me so okay
we took this tape what did i put you on
comics unleashed oh i put you on comics
on leisure but i created that show for
you and others just like you i wanted a
home where comedians could shine so so
okay so i put you on there
was this your tv appear this was i was i
believe i was i a writer on last couple
of carson daly at this point i don't
work i think that might have been
afterwards my first tv appearance
standing up on the late night show was
last call with carson daly but i think i
was on comics unleashed before that my
parents were there both it was the first
time they had been together since they
had gotten divorced wow and uh they came
to watch you mm-hmm it was one of the
like great days of my life i'll cry and
um i'm so bummed i had bangs and that's
so what else all right so our first
meeting you you i love this you came up
you dropped the tape off eric is sitting
here he gets the tape he shows it to me
and i always love
new comics i always love you know smart
comics so what else did we talk about
that then later i came in for another
meeting and you in my conference room in
my in your conference room and you
explained sort of the business of comedy
to me in a way that i very uh largely
credit for a lot of the things that i
built because i realized oh you don't
get to
it's not your creative or your business
minded everyone told me if you're a
comedian you're a mess and if you're a
business person you're not funny that's
right and i was like i guess i have to
pick one you know and then i watched
what you built from jokes and being
funny and being a leader and i was like
oh i think i can do both of these things
and i saw it and i was like i can do
this and i also was talking to you about
you were like what are you writing about
like what do you care about and i was
like oh you know i'm trying to appeal to
everyone you know i'm female so i'm
writing about you know airplane food and
religion a little bit of everything and
you're like why would you do that then
how would your who's do it like find
your people find your lane and stay in
that lane and own that lane that's right
what's your favorite show what do you
like to write about and i was like well
my favorite show at the time you know
with sex in the city you know and you
were like well why don't you just be the
sex in the city of comedy that's exactly
right and i was like oh my god and then
every time i sat down to write i was
like if sex in the city was still on
what would the episodes be about and
then all of my stand-up was revolved
around that that's exactly right and
that's that was my whole thing as i said
whitney you are unique your fingerprint
is unique don't be afraid to show who
you are and be unique and share with
people what you think and you feel and
you will do great
you made me realize that what i thought
my weaknesses were were actually my
superpowers that's right and that's
something that i think a lot of people
don't get that because you're like well
you're a woman it's not gonna be you're
like no there's less of you this is even
better that's right why wouldn't you
lean into this you know so i was like
well let me be just like the guy so i
fit in with them no and then you fix my
credit that's it
oh that's right that was oh that was the
other thing yeah i said you know do your
standards yeah this is your point of
view be yourself share who you are be
unfiltered don't be afraid to be you you
are unique and that's yeah and then yeah
you were telling me about you had really
bad credit
and you you could just feel the
brokenness
from me and i said what's the story you
told me your credit was like i don't
know 200 or something like that and i
thought okay well you're never going to
be able to get an apartment you're not
going to be able to get a car so i said
do me a favor i said call this guy
and i said because i had really bad
credit from when i started my company
for my dining room table 30 years ago
and they were turning off my phone and
they were fork i think they foreclosed
on my home i think 14 times so
i said call this guy he'll fix your
credit and he'll get you back into the
700 800 club and then all of a sudden
you people will be throwing money at you
so you did call them we love you michael
farhan yeah yeah
and that was the main thing and i just
said get that going so because that's a
lot another thing a lot of people i also
sat down with someone who had their shit
together and i was like wait a second i
thought to be funny you had to be a mess
and your life had to be a mess and
mentally you had to be a mess because
you know comedians you know you glorify
sort of the you know the drama and stuff
and i was like oh yeah in order to be a
successful business person and comedian
i have to get my mental health right i
have to get my finances in order like i
can't be distracted and uh depleted
energetically by all these you know
crazy distractions like i need to make
this a full-time job and i didn't
realize you know that i had to get my
house in order in order to get my career
in order and that was a huge part of it
that's why i'm always worrying about my
credit i can't be free i can't be
playful i can't be creative it's okay to
be happy and healthy
and that's something
people have to
have that conversation and make that
commitment to themselves
i deserve to be
happy and healthy and what makes me
happy
and don't feel guilty about what makes
me healthy
what brings joy to me life is so
precious
it the next second is not promised
be happy be healthy enjoy your life and
be around people who feel the same way
and conduct themselves the same way and
don't let them drain you but sometimes
people you know like glorify this
busyness and self-deprivation it might
be uniquely american who knows but
sometimes people need permission to you
know because i think we also tend to
conflate productivity and busyness and
it's almost like people think they're
going to get a trophy for who's the most
miserable now yeah do you know what i
mean like people brag about it they're
like i didn't sleep last night i skipped
lunch but and you're like you're pr
how did we start rewarding
self-deprivation and misery because i
think on some level we equate it you
know i definitely learned growing up
like if it's not hard it's probably not
good right you know so i think i'm like
wait a second that was suspiciously easy
and fun and like i love all my employ
we're having such a good time like could
this possibly be good you know so
sometimes we just need someone to say
like it's okay to be happy you know it's
okay knowing when you're miserable your
whole life no one gives you a check at
the end that's exactly right because you
were like i wasn't happy for 80 years in
a row where's my trophy
no that never happens you know
but i'm fascinated by the your uh the
skills from doing stand-up in your
business life we are able to kind of
feel things and sense things you know i
can go on stage i'm like that's a
terrible day they've been married
forever that he's cheating we just feel
that's right what have you learned um
about in terms of the hiring process of
like i love talking about when people
come in what's the biggest mistake you
see people make what's the most
important question to ask a future
employee and like what have you sensed
in terms of the hiring process of who's
a valuable asset i.e um when i was doing
a talk show this was 10 years ago at e
entertainment uh someone recommended
this girl named
lauren greenberg she had hilarious
tweets hilarious tweets and i was like
we got to bring her in she came in she
was not had no writing experience at all
she was working at a company where she
was trying to promote on instagram
these cups that measure your food so you
don't overeat
and uh she was miserable in the job and
she'd write tweets from her job and i
asked her like are you dating anyone
super appropriate thing to ask in a work
meeting but
i like to throw people off i don't want
to look at your resume i lied on my
resume this means nothing like your
resume is nothing that's right and so um
and so i was just trying to kind of and
it's a personal show and we make jokes
about dating and stuff and she um had
just uh experienced her mom putting her
on j date without her permission with a
photo that like wasn't of her like it
was something and she started balling
crying and then the meeting just got
weirder and weirder and she was crying
and sobbing and then left and
i knew i was gonna give her the job as
soon as she started crying i knew it
right and i felt like it was kind of
cruel cause i was like i should just
tell her and i was like i'm gonna let
her sweat it out a little bit you know
just let her sweat it out you know and
um gave her the job and she was
brilliant uh lauren greenberg she now uh
is head writer and james corden yeah and
it was like something that ostensibly
seemed like a big faux pas in a meeting
i was like this is important because
she's vulnerable she's honest she has
draw i don't want someone coming in
that's like perfectly together and makes
no bad decisions and has never had you
know because for the job that i need her
for i need that's what i want and need
you know so i'm just curious my because
my instincts were just like this person
right is great even though on paper this
went horribly yeah i mean you know what
well i in the beginning i was
interviewing everybody and what i was
looking for was simple are you smart
because if you're smart we can teach you
whatever you need to know
i just need to know you're smart enough
to learn it
are you a happy person are you a good
person are you a positive person
because if you're that everything else
will take care of it if someone can't do
something do you want them to admit it
yeah because we can teach you everything
you know none of this is brain surgery
none of it we can teach you whatever you
need to know that's why you're here i
don't expect you to know it all right we
we want you to be
smart
we we love it if you're smarter than us
please yeah right i mean one of the best
things you know for us when buying the
weather channel
close to 400 employees
a lot of smart people
buying the weather channel made us
better
like they were just so smart who's going
to elevate me who's going to elevate me
who's over qualified
all day long when i go to buy companies
i look at that
the human i look at the human resources
i think for human resources that's the
most valuable asset in any company
because you can build anything if you
have smart people
so that's very important i think i think
microsoft employs more phds than
anybody well okay so you just want that
so are you smart
and are you a good person are you a nice
person because we've had people that
were negative
and it's hard to get around negative and
let me ask you a question because for
everyone in in you know um because this
is by the way a good for you university
episode we do like good for you you you
know we'll have doctors on people like
you and um so what's the difference
between constructive feedback and just
negativity because i think people fly
when they declare it's not going to
happen
it's when they're when they're declaring
we can't do that the tiniest obstacle
and you've given up that drives me
insane that's that's that's it i called
they haven't called back
yeah it's like drive to their office i
mean i may dr go over there you know but
it's just the tiniest obstacle it's not
going to get done it's not going to get
you did the least yeah and i say to my
salespeople i said you know you know
listen when they say no
that's when you go to work one closer to
a yes you you don't have business no
means yes and like and sales that means
you go to work like if they just said
yes do you think i would hire you
i don't need you if they're going to say
yes
i need you to convert the no's into
yeses so if you say to me you didn't get
it done because they said no
then what you're saying is i don't need
you i could have gotten to know on my
own but i'm an email and i could have
settled for a no right then and there i
pay you to convert no's into yeses how
do you think we built this company off
of no's or yeses why do you think you're
here because you think when you get off
my elevator right on our floor there is
a sign by the elevator that says there
isn't a bank in the world where i can
deposit excuses so i don't accept them
byron allen
boom
if you are in sales you got to figure
out how to get that yes
bottom line
you figure it out go get it done
because i had to do it you have to do it
i did it with no email that's exactly
right what's your excuse
i did i didn't have email i mean i had
to call up and it's so funny i would uh
i would call tv stations to carry my
television show and i literally called
all
1300 stations 50 times each they told me
no and after working through 50 000 no's
i was able to squeeze out 150 yeses to
sell the first show entertainers with
byron allen and the general managers
they literally
stopped taking my calls they would just
stop taking my calls and i said okay
well that's not an excuse
and uh so what i did is i called the
receptionist at the tv station
and i would say oh uh can i go to the
newsroom
and they would transfer me to the
newsroom because they thought i had a
story
and all right
so because they always pick up because
they think you know i saw something you
know right yeah
whatever it is right so they transferred
me to the newsroom i go oh my goodness i
didn't mean to get the newsroom can you
send me to the general manager bob
now bob's the general manager is the
general manager of the tv station the
general manager of the tv station is
always going to take the phone call from
the newsroom
right so then they would patch me in and
then bob would pick up and i say bob
it's byron needs to buy that show
now bob don't make me come to your house
you buying you're gonna buy my show so
i and i love sales i love
i love sales
i love comedy i love doing sales do you
have to love people i love people i love
using humor in sales
uh you know when i pitch i make my i
make my clients laugh sometimes and
sometimes i'm hard on them sometimes i'm
very frank with them nobody is i don't
they don't come across people like me as
open i said you don't do enough you're
not leaning in you're meaning you're
minimizing yep you know i think your our
relationship is disrespectful you're not
appreciating me i mean i talk to them
like nobody talks because
as a comedian that's my training i'm
open i'm unfiltered just like i said to
you be yourself
and you always have to address the
elephant in the living room when you get
on stage if something's weird you gotta
address it if someone breaks a glass you
gotta say something that's exactly right
did they notice it did they say anything
and then everyone is mommy and daddy
fighting again and they go you've lost
all your power because you everyone
knows something you don't that's you
have to know more than everyone so that
you're in control that's right so you
have to like be able to call everything
out because if everyone's thinking about
something and you don't know yet it's
just egg on your face and there's
something so soothing about like i'm in
good hands as soon as someone addresses
the elephant in the living room now i
can trust you yes that you're in charge
that's exactly nothing gets past you and
we're not in this pretend time may i ask
what you've learned about human nature
like is there any sort of um in order to
sell someone this you gotta this like my
dad used to always tell me
if you if you're not getting along with
someone or something's the ask them
three questions about themselves you
cannot ask someone three questions about
themselves and not find a way to like
them it probably just means if you're
not getting along with someone it
probably means you haven't asked them
enough about themselves and you've
probably just talked too much about
yourself because you've probably made
assumptions you have some you know
predisposed of what this person is just
ask them where they're from ask them
their favorite team growing up and ask
them what their dad did for a living you
know just three simple ques and then all
right now now we're both human beings
here yeah you know so that's something
that has helped me is there anything
else like you that you've learned about
just like human nature
you know first of all that was great
advice that's great advice from your
father and everybody should use that
that's amazing advice i mean for me in
terms of just human nature
be honest be open people know they know
when you're honest and they know when
you're open
and just because you think you're
getting away with the lie doesn't mean
you are no i think everyone knows
everything they know and and i think
you're not no one's getting away with
anything right and i think you know for
me in terms of it you know it's trust
that's the big one you know you want
them to trust you and you need to trust
them i mean it's a big deal like i don't
care how much money i lose i'm not
laying anybody off in this global
pandemic i don't know what's going on
but they have to trust me
they have to
know that i have them and i have to
trust them right it's the same thing
it's just trust
you know uh i wanted television stations
to know you can trust me to deliver the
show i wanted advertisers to know that
i'm really i'm here to entertain the
family i'm here to make it better once
people know they can trust you they're
going to work with you and listen
business is very much like life life is
like business it's never going to be
perfect it's never going to be smooth
you're going to hit your speed bumps
you're going to hit your speed bumps
you're going to hit your potholes
but people if they know you they know
hey that wasn't your intent mm-hmm they
know your character can be the benefit
of that they're going to give you and
because that's just really who you are
and tell them and especially you know
what we do here in tv yep
i've always said you know you know you
look at somebody like oprah winfrey
she's amazing
she's just an amazing human being and
why is she so successful because she's a
good person and you can't be on tv every
day for an hour
and hide the lie
you have to be a really good person
and because the one thing that camera
won't do is cover up who you are yeah
that you're a bad person that you just
you know like it really comes out
television is so intimate
and i think that you just have to be
good and if you're not it's gonna you're
gonna have a tough time with that
particular meeting
because we spend so much time as
comedians as performers as business
people words words words are the most
important thing words we're emailing
we're choosing words ultimately when it
comes to communication the irony is that
most of it is nonverbal who are you and
do people like you when the sound is off
and that's right who are you are you a
good person it will come through you
cannot hold it back and if you're good
and you're likable oh hello hello we're
taking a little break from this
titillating conversation
to address why do i feel the need to
perform in every moment like that exact
segway i felt that i didn't think i was
a nut i didn't think i could go now a
word from our sponsor right and you
should listen to other podcasts because
they literally do it like this oh yeah
now we're in from response terms and
better household ingredients like
cardboard talking and then they go back
to the show be specific who no
damn it
that does though feel like something you
should talk about
in therapy
well that's the thing i am going to uh
that's a word from our help
therapy
speech therapy how a word from our
sponsor better help we have to start it
like sorry oh we do yes i didn't realize
that okay thank you emily
um i mean here's the problem if emily
gets any more uh like secure or
self-esteem these ads are gonna be a
mess like you being do you ever think
like i do fine though i'm like if what
if i get too healthy do you ever do yeah
i think a lot of people
resist therapy a little bit because
you're like well what if i have this
breakthrough that makes me have to leave
the person i'm with or like oh hundreds
i'd rather just because i remember one
time a therapist said to me because i
was working so hard because it's so
addictive once you start realizing that
are there all these solutions and that
what you can control and what you can't
that's like the best feeling ever like
oh i can just like
you know not call my mom for the fourth
time today right like i can just you
know i feel attacked i think you are
being attacked um but like or whatever
where you're just like oh that could be
a text or that could be a voice member
okay just like the smallest little
things can be so mind-blowing just in
terms of reparenting yourself and making
like breaking habits yeah but i remember
the therapist said to me they're like be
careful because
the the healthier you get the lower
number of people you can date oh or even
have your life really true or yeah and
just having your life have around you be
like
in your inner circle yeah when you want
to be a better problem solver therapy
can get you there there is no excuse
anymore pull it together i promise you
your success in life your happiness is
all linked to how uh your thoughts flow
smoothly and uh
and the thoughts that don't flow
smoothly you're not in control of you
let them pass by like a cloud yeah
that's what really helped me yeah and
also it's like watching a science
fiction movie yeah in your brain a lot
of the things that you think are just
science fiction this person hates me
this person doesn't like me if i don't
go to this birthday party they'll never
talk to me again it's like literally jj
abrams directed your thoughts nolan
can't come up with a plot twist this
good but just enjoy it enjoy it for the
entertainment it is and it's also just
like what a small
like i think that you think about me 48
hours a day
you know what i mean like i don't think
you could possibly think about anything
this is a bad example because i might
there's like a strong chance the other
great thing about better help is that
the number of fucking
times i see a top i want to like
send you
like everything reminds me of you every
time i see a fucking baby not because
you love babies because the way they
dress
is that emily um that's why i can keep
you out of therapy because if you get
healthy enough you're gonna get rid of
that every time i see a stroller i'm
like
yeah i'm just just are you in there on
that note another great thing about
better help is that you can switch your
counselors so easily yeah i once went to
a therapist to find a way to get rid of
my old therapist like i had two
therapists at the same time and managed
breaking up with one yep don't worry
about that with better help so easy
match you can change it so go to better
health i'm sure the therapist was our
program while she's getting a lot of
money from me
that's better help betterhelp.com
whitney back to the show
cool i don't have to hear about all the
sketches that got cut from snl
i don't have to hear about who jost is
dating now
byron are you hiring
did i ever tell you about one time i ran
into seth meyers who was running snl at
the time you might have been working
there at the time there was a pitch
about comics unleashed where uh that
that's how you know something has hit
the zeitgeist like snl is pitching
sketches about it and the sketch was
that
people comics kept getting the wrong
setups right from me
that was such a funny idea because you
were always so respectful about making
sure everyone had their time because
comics we all want to steal each other's
light and tag each other's jokes and you
would really make sure that especially
people that were just you know starting
and because you would pair unknowns with
like legends right you know so you'd be
kind of you know doing your thing and if
someone else wanted to steamroll you and
you but you would really so just the
idea that you're like so you just hurt
your knee skiing and someone's like i
don't think that tell me about it
they're like
at the beginning the show was so new and
i was really bad at setting up all the
comics and i was always i loved it yeah
i was always trying to like be smooth
about it but i was just trying to get
them in there and these comments cause
it was like it was a new concept it was
so new how do these comics work together
how do they blend in
and it was really challenging and i got
the idea i had the idea in my head for
decades
as a kid i used to write for jimmy
walker
and so jimmy i it was like my first or
second time on stage and this comment
comes up to me and he says who wrote
those jokes i said i did he goes can i
get your phone number i said yeah he
goes i know somebody may be interested
it was wayne klein
and i get a call from jimmy walker and
he says hey my man can i speak to buyer
i go speaking of come on my man wayne
kline says you're funny
and if my man my man wayne klein says
you're funny then you must be funny
and i go i'll tell wayne i said hello i
love wayne and he goes do you want to
come right with me and my boys i go okay
let me ask my mom and he was like oh
he's got to ask his mom i was 14 years
old at the time my mother says yes she
lets me go over to jimmy's apartment i
walk in there and sitting there is david
letterman
who had just driven out from
indianapolis in his orange or red pickup
truck he wasn't sure he was going to
make it so he wanted to be able to get
in his truck and drive home i've seen a
photo of you guys sitting around yeah is
that in your is it on my internet is it
okay i don't know where but yeah you
know what's interesting about that photo
is i if somebody had said to me
at one point in your life you had on
plaid pants
i would have said no that wasn't me
you you you have the wrong person that
was not me and then i and then they
showed me this phone oh my god i'm
wearing plaid pants
like what happened how did that happen
so anyway so i was walking around
so i guess i showed up at jimmy walsh
your funny pants like your comedy page
like straight out of the circus
i'm like i cannot believe i was i'm
horrified like every time i see that
photo as like forget my afro
forget david letterman sitting there
great it's like the plaid pants like can
they shop that out photoshop that out so
so the letterman was sitting there and
uh jay leno
and who was who was sleeping in his car
off the 405. these are all like
unknown broke comics like i'm 14 and
they're 26. letterman leno like like
it's insane insane i was getting
25 a joke okay so if i sold a joke to uh
to jimmy pay me 25 bucks jay and dave
and all the rest they were on staff 200
bucks a week that's what they got paid
and i remember talking to jimmy about
this and saying you know jay and dave's
getting 200 bucks a week can i get 200
bucks a week he's like no no you're
going to get paid more than them i go
how am i going to get paid more than he
goes you're going to write me 10 jokes a
week and you're going to make 250 a week
so you know i i just remember sitting
with all of these young really smart
brilliant comedians were sitting there
and somebody said you know let's come up
with an idea an angle let's figure out
something and somebody said you know for
every question there's a funny answer
and i went wow that's a great idea for a
game show and that's how i came up with
funny you should ask so for every
question there's a funny and that was
that's been in my head since i was 14
years old wow sitting in that room and i
was like okay and it always and i said
you know what i'm gonna do a game show
for every question here's a funny answer
and i just went back
almost 50 years i mean 40 years right 40
years
so and then no one had thought of it no
one right no one no one thought of it
and no one pursued it and i said you
know the hardest thing is to take this
is a first game show funny you should
ask that's ever made it into year two
three or four what are we starting now
funny you should ask this fall season
six is coming up season six thank you
very much eric so you know but no game
show has ever gone into year two or
three that didn't come off of the
network
wow
right so it premiered on a network first
wheel of fortune jeopardy family feud
they all premiered on a network first so
i said okay we have to crack that code
so how did we crack that code i had all
the comedians come on all the writers
all the writers come and we went up into
our studio and and we said let's do the
television show funny you should ask and
let's act like we're taping it but it's
not being taped and we did over a
hundred episodes
in our offices
and they said why are we doing this a
hundred times i go because we don't have
the privilege of being on a network
and perfecting this show we have to at
least show up on the stage as if we're
coming off of year one so let's do a
hundred episodes just up in the offices
and we'll know when it's funny and then
we'll take it downstairs and so when we
shot our first episode
our very first episode it was as if we
had done it a hundred times i don't know
if people understand how brilliant it is
what you just said is because i always
complain like the first episode of any
show is the worst episode you shoot a
pilot you have the least amount of
chemistry yes the hairs you haven't
figured the cameras out you haven't
figured the lighting out yet and that's
the thing you submit and that's the
thing everyone sees first
it's when everyone's the most awkward
the kinks haven't been worked out yet i
always say like you should you know
shoot something the pilots scrap it you
know start over and you basically just
worked out those kinks off-camera so
when you came in it was already just
locked up that is just so wildly that's
billionaire mindset shit that is on some
we're going to measure twice cut once
that yeah and that was and i just said
let's just keep going and going and it
was just so relaxing when we got to the
stage it was like it was second nature
it was second nature and and we know it
works there's no nerves there's no fear
because when fear is present no other
emotion can exist you have all these
brilliant comedians and if they're like
anxious it's what's the point relax i
want them to relax right and then i
remember you know i i was doing the
byron allen show it was a once a week uh
one hour show on the weekends in 1988 we
shot the pilot
and uh and i wanted to do this show i
was on tour opening for kenny rogers
and uh this guy and kenny was great a
great crowd and this guy comes up to me
and he says damn that was funny
it's like it's just like that goes this
he go that was damn that was funny
scissors honey was that the funniest
damn thing you ever that was so funny
that part when you said kenny rogers was
your daddy oh i think i kissed my pants
and i go uh yeah it's really nice to
meet you i go what's your name sir he
said my name
is joe louis albritton
i said nice to meet you mr albritton and
i said uh and where where are you from
and he says well i'm from down low
mississippi but i i i started my
business here and but i live in
washington dc
and uh i own the abc affiliate in
washington d dc uh wjla that would be my
my initials joe lewis albritton and i
own the i own the bank in in washington
d.c riggs national bank
he goes uh
if you ever need any money call me if
you ever want to do something call me
and let me know next time you're going
to be in washington d.c and i said well
you know i'm going to be there tomorrow
funny you should ask
you that
and we were in l.a so
you're going to be in there he goes he
goes well listen ah then i want you to
come have lunch with me
so
i said okay so i i go to his i go to his
office in dc
and they say you know i say i'm here to
see mr albritton and i'm thinking we're
going to go downstairs and go somewhere
and grab a bite or something and go yes
he's been expecting you and
they say take me into this room i'm like
this executive room and i walk into this
beautiful it's just decorated
unbelievably decorated room and up on
the wall
is a check signed by ben franklin
riggs national bank is the oldest bank
in america started by
ben franklin
so like and this guy owns it and uh
he we you know i'm sitting there it's
just like the two of us this butler
comes from nowhere from out of the wall
and he's got gloves on and i'm like what
is going on here
you know and he's just get out this is
like i've seen get out you didn't get
out
so you know they come and they were like
you know here's the menu what would you
like to eat i'm like i've never been in
an executive private dining room like
this is on another level right i'm used
to going down to pup and taco and
grabbing some mcnuggets what's going on
right so then um
he we talk and he says what do you want
to do i want to do the byron allen show
it's a once a week show he says all
right what you need for that and i said
i need a couple of hundred thousand
dollars he goes sounds good to me
like that and then he goes so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna have
some uh we're gonna have some people
check you out and do some due diligence
on you oh why and i and i'm like oh 20
something years i'm like what the hell
is due diligence i don't know what
they're going to do to me but whatever
and they'll do it diligently they do it
so they call me and they call me up
about a two weeks later and they say wow
they said you know this they're based in
washington d.c
they're like you know we have very very
close ties to the fbi and the cia so we
have the best security people in the
world and we checked you out don garnett
we couldn't even find a parking ticket
on you
that's what he said he said so listen up
he says i'm going to send a guy out
there he's going to have a check well no
we're going to fedex you a check for a
hundred grand and then the guy is going
to show up
a couple of days later with the other
check for 60 grand and let's go ahead
and make the pilot for the byron allen
show
so that's how i got the money that's why
i got it oh
we we we shoot the pilot and it turns
out well uh i went and got roseanne to
be on the pilot and she was going to
premiere her show was going to premiere
and i said oh this show's going to be a
hit
because it's it's scheduled to be after
who's the boss oh and who's the boss was
the number one show
and i said to roseanne i said did you i
remember asking roseanne i said did you
get
one laugh
and she said yeah i said a hit sitcom
if you get two or three big laughs
you're mega you're done i said did you
get one laugh out like she all byron she
goes i got more than one okay right i go
you're after who's the boss the show's
gonna go top ten and six and they waited
because they waited for john goodman he
was doing a play but they couldn't find
dan they couldn't find and they pushed
it a season and they waited for john it
was obviously worth it great lesson
great lesson don't rush don't rush so i
shot the pilot and then i waited for her
show to premiere went straight to top
five and then i all of a sudden i had
the pilot for the byron allen show with
roseanne on it
so then they say to me where do you want
to tape the show
and i said
i want to tape it
at johnny carson's studio
and they went what
i go yeah johnny carson studio because
my mother had worked at nbc and he was a
tour guide and then later of publishes
and that's where i was introduced to
comedy watching johnny and red fox and
flip wilson and so forth and so on i
watched the i watched him tape the flip
wilson show and richard pryor was a
young comedian as a guest on the flip
wilson show right
so but i loved johnny's studio
and what because it was built by bob
hope
and what bob hope did is he built this
studio and he built stadium seating
and what it was is a lot of these tv
studios when you walk out there
the audience is sitting in a pit and it
forces you to look down
as opposed to looking up and so tell in
in television opening your eyes and
being open and looking into the camera
is so key
but you aren't able to do that if the
audience is sitting in a pit because
you're as a comedian you're going to
play the audience and your eyes are
closed did you know you gave me the
advice when i do my special to look into
the camera every night do some jokes
into the camera into cameras and i had
them start putting neon tape on the
camera so i knew where they were because
my first special was like you're
thinking you just want to make the
people laugh but this is looks like shit
if you're watching it at home that's
right connect with the audience and bob
at home at home and bob hope it built
this this stadium the stadium seating
and it forces you to open your eyes and
look at the people that are now going up
to the rafters
and he had this and i said let's do that
and also i said it's going to give me an
opportunity to be near johnny carson
and so they asked me well okay they
called johnny carson they said he never
does this he will never let you i said
look i said johnny carson tapes his show
from 5 30 to 6 30.
he's back in his car heading to malibu
at 6 45. i said he'll show up
in his parking spot at 2 p.m like
clockwork okay then he's going to go
upstairs he's going to work with the
riders going to come downstairs just a
few minutes to 5 30 behind the curtain
bam he's going to hit the mark and he's
going to be back in his car i said
friday night at 7 00 when he's on the
freeway heading back to malibu let's
strike his set
and put my set in on saturday
and i will knock out two shows on sunday
and we will put his set back in on
monday because they were doing best
stuffs and he will not be he'll barely
know that anything was touched when he
comes back here
two o'clock on tuesday i said just ask
him and
tell him that the request is coming from
me byron allen because he gave me my big
break i'm the youngest comedian to do
the tonight show with johnny carson i
was 18. and he saw me standing around
for
four years before he put me on tv
because i was waiting for my mother to
get off work so i would always stand
around and i would always position
myself to say good to see you mr carson
really liked that joke about so-and-so
mr carson and i would always you know
make mention that i'm watching his
monologue and after a year or two he got
to know my name he says thank you byron
good to see you byron
nice all right so i made it a point so
i'd always i gave him enough room but i
always say great joke about such and
such mr carson four years of just
being around them so that said just let
them know it's me and so they called me
but i said no way this is going to
happen they call me back they go oh my
god
they said we told him it was you and he
said absolutely he says you can strike
his set friday at seven o'clock
and i went thank you they go
that's unbelievable he's turned us down
so many times we don't even know they go
that's amazing right so i get in there
which is by the way just a fascinating
secret to success
ask ask that is that you have to ask
and and to and to be around successful
people and just to absolutely study them
study now and learn study right and that
was the key and then they said well
where do you want to park mr carson
splat he's a spot number one do you want
spot number two next to him i go
absolutely not
i go no i do not
they go why not i go because he has a
white corvette
my car is black and i am not getting him
my black paint on his white corvette
i said you know i was at the commissary
the other day
and i was having lunch with david
horowitz and david horowitz had a show
called fight back on kmbc with david
horowitz he was a you know consumer
advocate and i said you know you kind of
have his parking space back in the
corner and i think he does a great job
why don't you give david that spot
number two
and then
and then i'll take spot number three
next to david
[Laughter]
so david he took spot number two and i
took carson had one david had two and i
took three and i remember pulling up and
david's like wow byron he goes i really
want to thank you i heard you put in a
word for me and said i should have spot
number two i go david you are
unbelievable you you deserve this spot
he had this
he had this gold mercedes i'm like david
if i hit anybody's car i'm hitting your
car i'm not hitting cars
so i take spot number three but it was
perfect because now
i could have conversations with johnny
carson
and so i would pull in it'll look like
right around two o'clock surprise
surprise around the same time carson
would pull in i'm full-on stalking him
and so so he would i say hey how's it
going and i missed cars i said you see
my show uh saturday because i started
asking him to watch my show
and then he said you know okay and he
would give me feedback
and i said okay what do you think he
goes you need to pull back i go okay
pull back he goes pull back he goes
byron remember this he goes
the first half hour of my show
is a comedy show
it's a comedy show he says i come out
here i do a monologue i do a skit
and i do a little sketch and then i will
bring a guest out at about five minutes
to midnight or midnight and he says and
i have guest number one number two
number three
and he goes but the first half hour is a
hundred percent me second half hour it's
about those guests that i have on and he
goes pull back and help them shine
he goes your job and he goes don't step
in unless they're bombing don't move
don't make a move unless they're not
interesting he goes pull back and
position them to succeed
he goes let them shine if you let them
shine
you will shine and he says it's hard for
comedians to pull back and let other
comedians pull back you know there's
under emily's desk is a nerf gun that
she shoots me with if i ever interrupt
that's how hard it is for comedians to
not go for the joke go go for the joke
and he taught me that and i was like got
it
and i said this is what i'm going to do
comics unleash i'm not going to do a
one-hour show i'm going to do a
half-hour show and the whole show is
going to be
comedy
and i'm going to have two comedians to
the right two to the left it's going to
be diverse it's always going to be young
old black white gay straight asian
hispanic male female
and i want that diversity in comedy
and i'm going to pull back and my job is
to help them shine
and that's where i got it from was just
parking in the parking lot next to
carson pull back let them shine and you
will shine with them that's what he said
that makes me so ha it gives me like
chills because also johnny carson said
something that blew my mind is in
probably one of the only reasons i had
the you know confidence or interest in
starting a podcast is because he would
always say a b stand up joke is an a
joke if you do it extemporaneously in a
conversation right so there's no wasted
joke so it's like you know all comedians
we write pages and pages of jokes but
only like a couple of them actually make
it as like oh this will kill in a
theater and get an applause break but
then you have all these other jokes
you're like i like these but they're
kind of what we call like b jokes that's
right but you have all those in your you
know arsenal but if you just say in a
conversation on a talk show or on a
podcast yeah it's all of a sudden in a
joke nothing's ever wasted yeah and
johnny also what he said to me he taught
me he said
i'm a really good comedy writer but i'm
a better editor than i am a writer and
sometimes you do so much better based on
what you don't say right and that you
that you pulled back that you at so when
i work on funny you should ask i spent a
couple of days just going over the
questions and the answers like i'm go
and edit edit edit
i'll go through you know 500 you know
questions to get to the 100 that we do
that day because we knock out five shows
in that day
being a kid and having that opportunity
to be in nbc and waiting for my mother
to get off work and watching bob hope
and red fox and flip wilson it was so
it was such a great
learning experience for me it was it was
just amazing you know i realized early
on
watching bob hope and george burns
they were like made it very clear you
know it's not important to be the
funniest comedian
a lot of comedians they're just i'm
gonna be the funniest
i'm gonna be i'm the funniest the one
that lasts the longest
is the most likable
the most likable because funny will come
and go that's a flavor yup and it's
fashion it's fashion after two or three
years you're not my flavor that's not my
fashion
the most likable
and i would you know i said you know
people say well what's this i say dude
you have to remember who you are where
you are you're in their homes
you're in their bedrooms around their
children you're around their children
they have to trust you you have to be
likable you're so focused being
the funniest
so what i would do when i shoot comics
on leash
right i would shoot the show as you know
for an hour
i shot the show for an hour per episode
but i would cut it down to 22 minutes
okay so but what i was doing was is i
was taking a bunch of nightclub comics
who are used to being in a nightclub
saying whatever
saying whatever they wanted to say they
didn't care about who they offended they
didn't care about what they were saying
and i said okay now i'm in the edit room
and i'm going to make you
a television comic
you're gonna be likable
so you'll say byron allen you're so damn
corny
yeah i am but i'm the most likable and
how many do you know who's been on
television 40 years
do you remember so i'm like so yeah you
can go and and so i think so now you lay
it out say i've been on tv consistently
from 79 to now here we are in 2022.
because you've been out there trying to
be the funniest
and i'm out there saying
be likable you taught me i mean you
taught me so many things but you really
broke it down for me in a granular way a
while ago where you're like if you say
something mean yeah it's cheap yeah it
might be kind of funny in the moment
right but you know it's mean and it's a
cheap shot that's right people might
laugh right it might kill right but over
time yes they will kind of not they
won't be able to identify exactly why
yes they don't like you that much or
don't buy tickets to the show or oh
she's in town or he's in town but like
that's fine they can't articulate it you
turn them off everyone's too busy just a
part of their brain was like
and then you know so and you walked me
through sort of the history of comedy in
some people's careers of just like you
know
because i think today we're at this time
where everyone wants to be like well i'm
authentic i'm going to talk about all my
moods and i'm mad and i'm this and i'm
depressed it's like you don't need to
put all that on everyone that's exactly
understand that the people that are
consuming they they're busy they have
lives we're babysitters half the time
that's right no it's we're on in the
background people want to go i know if i
put on one of his shows i can go cook i
can do the laundry the whole family can
enjoy it when i funny you should ask i
mean i have families come up to me
they're like we watch marathons at
thanksgiving because all generations can
watch it you know my grandfather can
watch it and my toddler can watch it you
know and that is something to be
i think incredibly you know proud of as
a comedian because that means oh i'm not
leaning on cheap shot i'm not you know i
think when i started as a female comic
it was like
you know you tend to go so edgy and so i
guess for lack of a better word dirty to
try to neuter yourself or try to make
people think you're tough or you know i
i feel like i had this really hard armor
on me and when you told me about that it
wasn't like you're not allowed to talk
about being a woman you're not allowed
to talk about sex it wasn't that it was
just like choose the words wisely the
way you deliver something can totally
spin yes
how it is just you would say you'd be
like just say with a smile that's exact
exactly right just do just don't change
anything i'm not trying to silence you
or sensor you just like save and smile
that's right yes that's it that's
exactly so simple so simple those
nuances it's not about it's not because
we're in this moment right now where
everyone's like i don't care what people
think about me i know like you know i'm
radically authentic you don't you know
like me at my worst you don't deserve me
at my best there's all this like fake
self-help that's all about like what
other people think of you don't matter
okay well if you want me in the tv
business it does they're going to matter
they're your boss you work for them you
know and you really um
are such a big reason why i got so
specific about the words i use how i say
things like you know just to make sure
that something like that doesn't happen
because it is so tempting to do that
that sorry that cheap shot that's right
and then
it's just not worth it that's why we
shoot for one hour i am editing all of
that stuff that i think will turn people
off
and i'm editing and i'm saying i want to
keep her likable i want to keep him
likable okay that's a funny joke but
he's going to lose points and by the way
he's not going to be likable more than
ever so i think everyone as things get
bleak or ostensibly in the news people
want to be like darker more than ever do
we need to be more positive because
there's so much meanness online there's
so much meanness on twitter there's so
much of that i mean you can find people
being nasty to each other and actually
really funny there's a lot of really
funny people that aren't comedians
online with memes and this kind of stuff
but i think more than ever we have to
lean in to uh
be not
sort of taking the bait of going
negative and unlikable because it's like
cool or it's like other comics we'll
think we're cool or
it's not as funny anymore because
everyone's doing it that's exactly right
so actually being positive is the
edgiest thing you can do that's right in
an odd way now just be positive and and
just try to do whatever you can to be
likable i think for me that's what's
worked for me now there are other comics
they're the complete opposite they just
blow the room up and that's fine that's
fine but i knew that
i wanted to be in television and be in
television for decades you knew this was
a long game
it's a marathon not a sprint because a
lot of people just are like i want to do
this until i get the show or until i get
a movie career that's exactly right then
they just get their movies and then
they're done and also you know
the way i looked at it is is that
you know
you don't really make it as a comedian
very few people make it as a comedian
uh if you really think about it yeah
they're in a studio
you know they're in a studio at some
point to really become a household name
they're they're either making a sitcom
you know jerry seinfeld even though
you're this great phenomenal comedian
but more people are going to know you
for seinfeld right because that sitcom
is so amazing even though you are one of
the the best stand-up comics out there
and you dedicate yourself to it like
like intensely right
uh
you know they're going to know you for
your
movies
jim carrey robin williams you're going
to be in a studio they're going to know
you for your talk show ellen
jay leno david letterman they're going
to know you for saturday night live
if you're not in a studio it's tough to
make it very few people have made it
just as a comedian doing a special every
other year like a studio apartment count
a studio apartment exactly like a george
carlin yeah i mean like that's one of
the few like a david brenner like one of
the few
were
pure stand up
and they did johnny carson 8 000 times
or they did a special every other year
and they didn't have the hit sitcom or
the hit talk show or the movie most
comedians that's the door they're going
to go through
and that's when america is going to know
who they are
because this whole thing of having
exposure to comedians it's fairly new
yes when i started doing stand-up comedy
in 74 or 75 we were a bit of a freak
show we you know we were doing four
minutes for the most part coming you
know in between the circus acts and the
spinning plates on ed sullivan
you know and then all of a sudden cable
came along
and that's when comedians and vhs and
that's when comedians became rock stars
because people were able to see a
comedian do the art form for an hour an
hour and a half uninterrupted
and then boom it's like whoa you're not
just some little five minute act you
know on some variety show i'm watching
90 minutes of brilliance
i'm watching 90 minutes of unbelievable
stand up and then that's when it went to
the hole that's when comedians went to
the stratosphere and can i ask you that
now that people you know are consuming
things so many different ways and
sometimes in these little bite-sized
pieces like in my last special that i
just came out i found myself as i was
shooting it going
make sure that you can cut this into one
minute chunks yeah make sure this can go
on tik-tok and instagram and all these
things the same way that when i used to
do specials for comedy central you would
go because they would break it up you
would do four minutes seven minutes
seven minutes two minutes because i
think how the commercial breaks went and
the first special i did i didn't know
anything about that so they would just
cut it wherever four minutes you're like
so the other day i was at a and then it
goes to
my lab and i was like i had no idea yeah
you know no one's gonna come back if
they thought you know so then i started
going okay four-minute chunk up front
and then and then you didn't think in
terms of they're gonna change the
channel now you go like that first
minute right whatever's closing for you
on the road is your opener that's
exactly
you know that's what you do now get them
hard because yeah a lot of these
streaming services are like we can get
someone to start a special we can't get
them to finish it either because it's
not compelling enough because you
usually save the best for last or
they're like i'll watch the rest later
because everyone puts their clips on
instagram anyway or i'll you know or
i'll watch this later and then you just
forget about it you know so how do you
think that you know because i already
feel like i've seen i don't know if i'm
just projecting or getting older and you
know but
the way people use you know twitter
instagram all of it do you feel like
comedy has been changing at all based on
the way it's consumed this you know i'm
seeing less and less of these like long
amazing stories and these like longer
bits like are we selling out a little
bit as comics given this shorter
attention span no i don't think so i
think it's getting much much better
awesome um because you have a greater
talent pool
right and more access to that yep you
don't have to go to new faces you don't
have to which can i tell you you of all
people will appreciate this uh when i
was a writer uh roast writer on the joan
rivers roast the way that a lot of
comedians used to get discovers they
would go to montreal it was something
called new faces and it's you know new
comics and one of my jokes for joan
rivers was joan rivers has had so much
work done every year she books montreal
new faces
i love joe i loved her taking another
break real quick another quick breather
to talk about
the only way to take a breather
wine
it's summertime y'all
i guess that song
will smith it was almost like
it was weird because as the slap was
happening will smith to chris rock
i was like
there goes our summer anthem
like it's gone yeah he took that do you
know what i mean
yeah and so enter
wine
the days are hot
grill's going
not our grill but perfect time for i get
why though
wine enthusiasts i actually have your
product i actually use your product but
now that i see that other podcasts hosts
they phone in ads in a way that is
is truly shocking they phone in at i
mean mail podcast phone and ad reads the
way women phone and sex with them with
the way their wives phone in
orgasms yeah
so i see why they have to write things
out so clearly but then it's like we
actually have things to say because we
actually use the product yeah and the
egg white nose and then yeah totally
yeah we don't need this we we have this
product way before you spot yeah yeah
we love this and then we're like anyway
so it's summertime days are hot and
great i'm like it's in my garage it's a
miracle did you know that summer heat
and sunlight it can spool
your wand
and hence your good time
you don't want that you don't want
skunked wine no you don't have that
person where people come over and your
wine smells like vinegar vinegar
yuck dude don't be that guy it's
embarrassing because also the people
that don't know much about wine who i
used to be is they don't know if they're
if right if something's coming and
they're embarrassed right
embarrassed to say like oh yeah i think
your wine went by yeah
like sorry did you not do you you don't
have a seller yeah and then they just
think you yeah
like they just think you're in ketosis
or something you know it's bad news all
around wine is to be respected it is to
be coddled and just be just like me
loved it is to be uh honored the way
that it needs to be stored you know what
i'm saying i take better care of my wine
than i do my skin at this point which is
insane
got rid of the skin fridge kept the wine
enthusiasts fridge wine enthusiast
designs and offers the largest selection
of wine coolers for every drinker every
budget and every size collection from 60
to 600 bottles don't be that guy that
just has nine bottles six to six hundred
stop saying my age range on dating apps
on the podcast
but like uh it's uh gorgeous yeah the
fridge is gorgeous it's not this
albatross nothing drives me crazier than
when you go to someone's house and they
just have like wine bottles just out
yeah like first of all it's very college
how like frat house energy
top of the cabinets we are so due for an
earthquake it's routine oh god that's
why i need a wine fridge okay they also
have x and whiny wine they also have
expert wine storage consultants
available by phone to help you find the
right fit for all your needs where i put
this riesling teddy
back on the shelf top row sweet wine
enthusiast is the premier destination
for the wine lifestyle offering an
incredible selection of unique wine
accessories glassware furniture wine
storage gifts and more visit wine
enthusiasts.com or text the code gfy2511
511 and from now until labor day save
during wine enthusiasts labor day sale
save up to 50 on select wine cellars and
furniture now through labor day text gfy
to 511 511 not 911 even though it is an
emergency text gfy 511 511 today wine
enthusiasts.com they bring wine to life
certain exclusions may apply you may
receive up to one additional text
message and data rates may apply text
stop to opt out be a classy bitch you
know it's a great thing to do when
you're drinking wine place
bets emotionally or literally nope with
money
by the way the fact that we get to work
with draftkings is a really big deal
it's huge the fact that they are working
with us and none of us have cauliflower
ear is a very you don't know what my
ears look like when that's a really good
point
i have cauliflower posting out
the point is the wait is over a new
football season is about to begin i'm
actually really good i'm actually really
excited for football season no because i
have this screening thing now oh yeah
that's actually very i watched football
with giannis pappas that was so funny it
was so fun it's just i was watching with
the wrong people
you know what i'm saying it's like
watching it with my friend nick and
giannis is the most fun ever i just made
the mistake of watching football with
boyfriends in the past who care too much
emotional stability dependent on whether
the patriots won or lost
so i now i have the best time
watching football it is time to gear up
get ready for the nfl week one action
with draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl to
celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers a
can't miss offer bet just five dollars
five dollars on any football game and
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly
want more action on opening night
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion get up
seven you
win bet on any nfl team of your choice
and if your team leads by seven points
at any point during the game you get
paid
instantly yeah even if your team
loses cleveland
why'd you look at me i don't know
draftkings is a safe secure and reliable
site best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code whitney to get
200 in free bets instantly when you
place a five dollar bet on any football
game that's called whitney only at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details
back to the show with this you know
we can just call it a fragmentation for
now of sort of how people are consuming
news because you know the topical joke
every it used to be we're all gonna wait
to see what leno has to say we're all
gonna wait to see what letterman has to
say about today's events now you're
getting it in real time all the time on
twitter refresh refresh so now talk show
hosts have a slightly different
responsibility or they've had to what's
going to happen i did the
the cordon spot like this is what every
comic waits for right you know what i
mean we've all built up to oh my god
there's an opening in late night
you know what i mean and i was just
talking to cbs about it and i was like
it was like what does that look like is
that what do you see in terms of late
night i'm sure you have tons of plans um
do you think that someone going into
that cbs cordon spot
do you think that could ever be
something that
it will it ever be what it was what does
it look like in the future and is that
over
you know at the end that's a great
question you know i think the way it
works now is so funny my kids you know
chloe is 14 olivia is 12 and my son
lucas is 9.
they should be asking them then yeah
exactly i'm asking you yeah don't ask me
you know they they
they know corden and they know ellen
because of youtube
and the singing in the car the oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah karaoke
in a car i'm not yeah carpool carry so
you know it when i i looked at that and
i said that's really interesting like
they love
gordon they love ellen and it's all
because of youtube and so i'm looking at
this and i'm going oh i see what's
happening here
this talk show that's on the network way
past your bedtime
is basically funding
content
to be put on the web so you can discover
them and fall in love with them
so it's almost like it doesn't matter
what you do with 12 30 at night
the 12 30 at night doesn't even matter
it's what you do that can that can what
are you doing that can go viral it's an
advertisement for all like it's like snl
now people watch it chopped up the next
day chopped up the next thing people
talk about it what can i do tonight that
people can go viral well fallon really
started cracking when he had
nicole kidman on and the show actually
went sideways
and she goes remember when we went on a
date he's like what and he was she was
like you don't remember that and it was
like 40 minutes of like really bizarre
awkwardness and they put it on youtube
and it got like 50 million views and
we're like oh that's what people want
unpolished unscr things going wrong
that's right and then it was like oh
let's do chaos even though it's late
night and we all have so much reverence
for this format
actually you know people are sort of
over like the whole polished
overproduced thing i remember a couple
years ago i was in instagram offices and
they said that selfies do better i'm
sorry photos do better when there's an
arm in the shot that's right because
people go i'm not being played i know
it's not photoshopped i know this person
took it themselves show me what i
haven't seen before
carpool karaoke yeah show me what i
two people in a car being hilarious it's
almost like they want help me escape
lo-fi yeah help me escape be funny be
whimsical so i think look the 12 30 slot
whatever you do at 12 30 at night you
could do at 12 30 in the afternoon so i
think some of the world's biggest
comedians going forward will give birth
to themselves just like the story you
told hey she was tweeting oh what if she
was doing all of these funny lines
lauren
and she gave birth to herself she was on
social media yep self-generating
self-generate because she's talented and
i think what's going to happen now is
because before that when i started you
only had comedy clubs in la and new york
right and if you weren't in l.a in new
york then you had to you know
dream about being a comedian now you can
start being a comedian right where you
are
like right in your bedroom you know in
your backyard so that's going to expose
you to a lot of people that normally you
wouldn't have exposure to that are super
talented when i talk to these like
youtube stars and i'm like wait you can
use final cut you use final you can
shoot you can edit you know how cameras
work like you understand the concept of
tension you understand the concept of
you know the guy that um
you know i'm with he's only cons he's a
moving nut and we'll be you know writing
something and he'll
he'll be able to break down the
structure of things because he's
consumed so many movies he was like oh
then this is gonna happen there and then
that's gonna i'm like how'd you know
that he's like well that's always the
and it's like oh my god i've been so
busy making shows and trying to make
movies that i forgot watching them is
also very how you're going to learn and
then i need to figure out a way to
subvert all these formulas to keep
things surprising that's exactly right
and that's what these kids have now that
we didn't have coming up they have the
ability to take in 10 000 times more
than we took in and it works as data
points for them they know instinctively
because they've watched so much good
stuff and so much bad stuff
and they know and i think you're going
to see amazing content coming out going
forward because i think content is going
to get better and better not only
because they're making it but also
because
they can't like
they don't suffer fools you can't get
away with anything with that that's
exactly and they have too many choices
now so we're all going to have to step
up and the quality is going to have to
get better and better it's going to get
better and more global it's just going
to be global you're going to have it's
going to be like
you know when we came along it was just
more the norm to be a a comedy star in
america you're gonna have a lot of
global comedy stars well shows like the
office for example if you were to make
that today it is so based on
very specific american morays that's
right you know they have their you know
a party of chili's and that's the big
joke you know i'm always curious if like
the office was made today right with all
those super specific american cultural
references it's like what word is
offensive that chris rock said like
that's also we have been making comedies
only for america for so long that's yeah
i think it would work because people
want to know about other people yeah
people are curious they already know who
they are they already know their culture
what can you teach me about your culture
i want they want exposure they don't
have that exposure and we as human
beings were naturally curious
so that's why when you go on stage you
are helping to solve some of that
curiosity
you're like who is whitney you know
people want to know i mean that was
that's the genius of norman lear
look at the families he introduced us to
that we didn't know
people we didn't know like i'm inside of
archie bunker's house how do i get
inside of archie bunker's house unless
norman lear takes me there
we're curious we want to know and so in
this instinct where people go it's
global now we have to appeal to everyone
that shouldn't be the instinct the
instinct should be oh the more specific
you are the more universal you are like
be as specific as possible yeah and
that's how you will appeal to everyone
you're never gonna get everybody and
that's okay
you're talking about a you know global
population of 8 billion heading to 10
billion right whatever it is 7 billion
heading to 10. if you know in america
alone you're talking about 330 million
people if you had a single digit
percentage of that that's a big career
if you have you know five percent of
that that loves you you know 16 17
million people that's a big career so
you don't even need everybody you just
need to be who you are and clear as day
and then
you know people are attracted to you you
know like the genius of richard pryor i
loved as a kid you know i was at the
comedy store in the 70s and i watched
richard pryor come to the comedy store
and it was great for me to see it
firsthand because he had only had his
albums
is something i said blah blah blah so he
goes on stage
and people started crying when they saw
him
and he was just a real superstar like
literally full full grown men would
start crying when they saw
richard pryor and when he hit the stage
they started shouting out his comedy
routines like it was a hit record
you know do this one do the monkey and
all this and then
he went on stage
and he would
he bombed like he would get a 15-minute
standing ovation when he hit the stage
and then he stood there and he would not
repeat a word that was ever on an album
it was all new and he would bomb
and everybody go what the hell happened
and i remember him saying one night he
said byron
you're only as good as you dare to be
bad
oh
and
because it was hard to watch
him go on stage get a standing ovation
and just
bomb
and night half cause
so
like and i'm watching this and you're
horrified as a comic like he's just
bombing night after night and then
all of a sudden 30 days in 60 days in
the bombing turns into
this routine's working this routine's
working and the next thing you know
he ends up recording richard pryor live
which is considered the definitive you
know the definitive greatest stand-up
ever
and i watched him do that where it was
just he just kept talking and and
stretching and looking and the thing i
saw that was so amazing to me
i saw somebody go on stage
and talk about themselves like
i'm their best friend
and they're talking to you
and they're sharing with you their
deepest deepest secrets
and you can't help but love that person
when richard pryor is on stage and
saying you know my mother had you know
my mother was you know working in a
brothel and my grandmother owned it and
and i was sexually molested who's saying
that in the 70s
in the 70s and he's standing there and
he's so open
and it's like and someone who's supposed
to be a comedian no less is going i'm
not going for the joke first i'm going
for the meat on the bone first i'm gonna
tell you who i am we'll do with the
jokes in a minute i'm gonna tell you who
i am and i'm gonna tell you
uh you know what i'm feeling what i'm
thinking
you know the story you know that i heard
for years about that was that
richard and bill cosby had the same
manager and bill cosby was the first
comedian to sell out madison square
garden and they said we need another
bill cosby and they had richard doing
bill cosby's act
and he was out there you know acting
like bill cosby
and one day richard uh pretty much
cussed out everybody in las vegas
supposedly defecated on stage but he
made it very clear he wasn't coming back
and um he did it first amber heard
he wasn't coming back and then he went i
think he may have gone to san francisco
or something and he couldn't stop
listening to the album my favorite album
of all time marvin gaye marvin gaye's
what's going on
and that album was so
real even that's why it's so powerful
today that album
and he just said i'm gonna that changed
that album what's going on change the
trajectory of creativity
right that helped to give birth to a lot
of things and it was richard who
listened to that album and said i'm
gonna be as real and as raw
as what's going on i'm not gonna pretend
like i grew up in this wonderful
neighborhood that's disney world
i'm gonna show people what i was exposed
to and i'm gonna tell people what i was
exposed to and people were like nobody
has ever talked to me that way
communicated with me my very very best
friend
in life has never shared that with me
and that changed everything in comedy
how you approach it with that honesty
and sincerity and it really it was
inspired by music
and seeing how music was was accepted in
that way
and because when you're up there with no
because this is why musicians come up to
us they're like i could never do what
you do and we're like i can never do
what you do and they're like oh wait
there is nothing to i mean
you know music you can use to help set
the emotion you have something you know
this relying on noise every 15 seconds
relying on an involuntary response every
15 seconds just being yourself yeah and
to go as long as he was going and
tolerating that silence it's just like
it is an ultimate comedians can't do
that bravery context and and and and
jamie masada
uh had a comedy camp for foster kids wow
and at the laugh factory
and jamie you know called up and said
you know i bring foster kids in and i
want to build up their confidence and we
teach them stand up at the laugh factory
will you
come in and teach some classes and i
said sure so i go in there
and i'm watching these foster kids go on
stage
and this girl walks up on stage and she
must have been 13 14 i don't know she
was a teenager and she walks on stage
and she starts talking about being in
foster care
and she starts talking about the
families she's come into contact with
and it's real and it's gritty and it's
raw and it's painful
but what took me back
was that
i watched her do something that took
one of the greatest stand-ups ever
richard pryor
10 20 years to get there
she walked up there and she did it
probably her third fourth fifth time on
stage she said this is what i see
and i said to her
i have to tell you something if you ever
look in the mirror
and ask yourself do i have it can i make
it
please know this you more than have it
i'm just telling you i've never seen
anybody
your age walk on stage and be so open
and raw and gritty i've watched full
grown men take decades to get to the
point you are day one and she said thank
you and it turned out to be tiffany
haddish
i saw that and i was like you have no
clue
who you are and what you're doing right
now
i'm telling you what you do naturally
is one of the hardest things in the
world for somebody to do stand there and
talk about your pain
and you talked about it
unfiltered and i said you you just have
to know you more than have it
that that's the hardest thing in the
world
to
ever
you know you can't teach that because it
is
you're embarrassing yourself on purpose
so that your
shame is almost dissolved it's like you
know who was it that um said i think
it's probably chris rock i just don't
want to plagiarize of um we become
comedians to control how we're
embarrassed
which i just kind of love just the idea
of like i'm gonna admit all the most
embarrassing painful things about myself
so i like we can all heal like it's just
this
you know it's therapy do you think
anyone gets you're paying me to do the
therapy exactly
in your opinion do you think anyone gets
the credit they deserve as a comedian
while they're alive
uh some do mm-hmm i mean i mean i i
seems like richard did yeah oh god yeah
richard i mean we love richard pryor we
love eddie murphy you see it george
carlin just one of the greatest minds
ever like so smart you know just like
there are a number of them they're just
people who really love
making you laugh i mean what a
what a human being
i just want to make you laugh just want
to make the world better that's to me
right now in this moment and then i
promise i'll let you go i'll end on this
notion of i don't know if you saw nor
mcdonald's um
special on netflix it's the last one he
filmed before he
passed
it's worth seeing he's reading off of an
ipad and he's just kind of reading jokes
and he's just being norm you know and he
said something that i just love so much
and i won't stop repeating it where he
goes it's in joke form but he goes um
you know why is everyone now looking at
comedians to be like moral political
leaders and our take on political issues
like when vietnam was happening was
everyone like oh i wonder what red
skeleton thinks
like why are you looking at comedians to
be these moral authorities etc but
whenever people are you know beating up
on comedians these days of oh you said
this and you weren't supposed to say
triana you're supposed to say this now
and you're not allowed to say this and
you're it's like we are just trying to
make strangers we've never met laugh for
even a second like just know if we get
it wrong no one's more mad at
us than us that's right like we just
like it's the same thing when you know
people like well these romantic comedies
they create these impossible standards
it's like just so you know the person
that wrote this movie hates themselves
and was just trying to make their
parents love them so they wrote this
stupid thing because they've never been
no one's ever loved them so they don't
know how love works so they just wrote
this movie because they you know so it's
like there is this new thing where can
people look at comedians as like bullies
or we're punching down like all that
it's like we really just are tr we are
trying to make someone we have never met
we have no idea how they voted we have
no idea if there's a serial killer in
the audience i want to make them laugh
we go to prisons to make criminals laugh
like we just want to make people laugh
and i think people forget that because i
guess comedians have been thrust to the
frontal line all of a sudden as like
moral authority figures like and it's a
very interesting thing i would just love
to end on just your thoughts in general
about this like pressure comedians are
feeling
right now
um you know
i don't like the word cancel culture but
like just in terms of like in the past
this has happened before this pressure
you know whether it's been um you know
on the simpsons that happened eminem
like there have been these big
cultural let's cancel it make it go away
outcry you know this has happened before
right right you listen i think you know
we're in a unique time uh unique times
here you know there are folks out here
media is so powerful right
and you can use you can weaponize media
and you can weaponize media in a way
where you can divide a country you can
overthrow a country you can pull a
country down weaponizing media
and we as comedians we're part of that
landscape
we are giving you the news we're giving
you the events we're giving it to you in
a humorous kind of way in a funny way
and an interesting perspective so you
have folks who want to control the media
they want to control the narrative
and as part of that campaign of trying
to
take over this country
they are shutting down the voices
especially if the voices don't
regurgitate what they say
and what they think and what they
believe
so the comedians are the last line of
defense
we are the last line of defense for true
you know truth tellers you know the ones
who are telling it the way it is
and getting the confirmation as people
are laughing and making people need it
so
they are
trying to shut the comedians down
it won't happen
because
you can't shut the comedian down why
can't you shut the comedians down
we are the original dtc
direct to the consumer
we are the we're we invented dtc direct
to the consumer we're direct with the
audience we don't need anybody else
other than our thoughts our mind we have
the audience the audience is with us
you can't cancel that you can't shut
that off
we have a relationship with these people
and they have a relationship with us and
they care about us we care about them
and they care about what we think so
you're not going to cancel a comedian
yes yes you can try and cancel a
comedian but guess what
you don't have that power they might not
do the today show anymore right like but
that doesn't matter what what matters is
they have an audience and they have a
relationship and they have social media
and the audience is there and loves
their opinion may not agree with all of
their opinions just like you don't agree
with all of the opinions of your best
friends and your loved ones but you
don't cancel them
some of the craziest stuff you've ever
heard of from your best friends or your
loved ones you're like did you just say
that what the what's wrong with you it's
the same relationship with a comedian
you're not going to cancel us you can't
cancel us and we already we have a
relationship that you wish you had
we are direct to the consumer
and we have a very strong relationship
with them and they trust us and all
we're doing is sharing our opinion
all we're doing is giving our point of
view
and if you don't like it then you're
going to move on and
i think a lot of people are forgetting i
trust someone more
when they say something i don't agree
with right in front because then i'm
like oh no i can trust you when i when
you say something i do agree you know
what i mean part of the trust building
process is going like oh i can take that
i can take that but i know this person's
always telling me the truth right
but i don't have to agree with
everything they say back you know a
couple years ago talking to someone that
disagreed with you or watching a comic
that had a different take that was just
called like an interesting conversation
where i get to hear the other side you
know right i mean listen i think
saturday night live is brilliant i think
they do an amazing job
and
i think they helped her using comedy uh
comedy is the most powerful thing out
there in my opinion it really is in
terms of helping to shape opinions
and shape you know points of views
and
you know saturday night live they use
that power very well
um i'm a fan of that show and how they
use it and how they communicate that
point of view i mean you've seen it with
you know
just the sitcoms and how you introduce
the families these american families and
now it's you say okay
it isn't about
tolerating because we don't want to
tolerate one another yeah yeah yeah we
want to celebrate one another and when
you introduce these american families
it's going to move the needle
like when i saw ellen get her show her
daytime show
i said to myself this is great you know
what's going to happen now now we're
going to achieve gay marriage
you know why we're going to achieve gay
marriage is because she's openly gay
she's brilliant she's wonderful
she's engaging and
american women are the most powerful
people on the planet
and these american women are going to
fall in love with ellen because she's on
every day for an hour
she's going to make them laugh and make
them happy and make them smile you know
what these american women are going to
say
they're going to say i love ellen
and i want ellen to be happy
so if if gay marriage is important to
her i need they're going to say to their
brothers their nephews their daddies
their sons
stand down
because also stand out because that
power
like all of a sudden there isn't this
what's this big question mark about a
gay woman mm-hmm like there's no
question she's been in my living room
she's my family she's my family
like that power of television and using
the medium of tv and the power of comedy
and all of a sudden the defense has come
down and the notions come down whatever
pre preconceived no it all kind of fades
away
and now we can get to that human which
is we're just the same and that's why we
do go like oh we're not curing cancer
it's just television i used to be like
that but then again
like what you're saying and then
michelle obama did this call with show
runners right before uh she left office
saying we can now put the pieces
together we can connect ellen and we can
connect uh will and grace to the passage
of marriage equality you know what i do
what i've i've always said about norman
lear you know if you don't if norman
lear doesn't introduce us to san francis
you know sanford and son and good times
and the jeffersons i'm not sure you get
other african-american family sitcoms
and then i think i'm not sure you get a
beautiful african-american family in the
white house
you know you just can't show up and not
have african-american families in the
white house i mean on television and all
of a sudden you go from zero to an
african-american family in the white
house you need humor and the power of
television to start introducing what is
an african-american family like right
and introducing that to america make it
no big deal make it no big deal like who
because it isn't a big deal who is ellen
who are these people like meet them
and television and humor is one of
sometimes the only way we meet one
another and get to know one another and
you go that's great thank you and that's
how we have to use
in my opinion we have to use humor and
we have to use the power of this medium
we have to use the power of media to
unite us and that's what i've always
been about i've always said for me you
know uh because you know coretta scott
king she was very clear about it and and
how she said look byron the truth is our
greatest weapon that's what martin
luther king's um uh widow and and and
that changed that changed my perspective
and how i saw myself and she said to me
look byron you know as black people in
america we have four major challenges
number one in slavery number two in jim
crow number three achieve several civil
rights and then she said something to
change my perspective forever when she
said number four the real reason they
killed my martin achieve economic
conclusion
and she said
they didn't kill my martin over the
speech i have a dream they killed him
over the speech the other america and
she said that he gave that speech in
february of 68 to stanford university
and they killed him two months later and
and from that moment on i've always said
i want to help
create that one america because in that
speech he said there are two americas
one america has access to opportunity
education and economic inclusion and the
other america doesn't two americans will
not succeed we must achieve one america
and you you can use media to help
achieve that one america that's you know
to help everybody lean in and understand
the power of what that is you know for
me that i call it the five e's make sure
everybody has a great education that
first e that's the first
america nailed that all right yeah every
he that he is there my mother got
pregnant with me when she was 16 had me
17 days after her 17th birthday nobody's
betting on a teenage black girl having a
little black baby in april of 61 in
detroit mission michigan is gonna go
anywhere okay but what changes that is
that my mother and i came here to la in
summer 68 for a two-week vacation and
she ended up getting into ucla and
getting her master's degree in cinema tv
production and because she was getting
she gotten her master's degree from ucla
and cinema tv production she was able to
go ask for jobs and she went to nbc and
said can i get a job here and they said
no and then she asked the question do
you have an intern program where i can
work for free and they said no and then
she asked the question that changed our
lives forever will you please start one
with me
and they said yes
and that's when i got i wish she
couldn't afford child care and that's
when i would go to work with her and i'm
seeing johnny carson and bob hope and
red fox and see that's it did you ask
her why she had the audacity to ask that
because she had she had no choice she
had to take care of a little baby she
had a little boy desperation is your
friend and she had a little boy that's
the leverage but that e is everything
education
education was a guy name was a professor
so arthur klein a professor at ucla was
head of the film school and he said
open the door and let her in
god bless him and you know that educate
like you don't like that's another
parallel
that you got into ucla you get education
you have to have it
and and that is so critical you know i
keep saying to america let's stop
talking about crime
until we fix education and economic
inclusion because that doesn't exist if
we yeah right ahead of it and once we
fix crime and once we fix and we bring
balance and economic inclusion
crime will start to once we fix
education and provide economic inclusion
crime will start to evaporate so that
first e is everything it's everything
education and we have positioned people
to fail that second e that's second can
i ask you one more about the first eve
since you have kids in school do you
look at the our education system
obviously everyone's at different kinds
of schools do you go
there are some things missing here oh
yeah listen we look i think the whole
emotional intelligence i think it has to
be completely overhauled i think that it
has you know i think we need to
quadruple put a 4x on teacher's salary
x like whatever you're making truly it's
like like multiply times four if not
five i don't care you can do a 10.
because you're developing our
intellectual capital and it's our
intellectual capital that will keep us
afloat it's everything
educa like it's amazing that it's the
one thing that we don't invest in like
we've made everything a business accept
education we've made incarceration
a business if you told me my taxes were
going to teach your salaries going up i
would never complain about taxes well
you know what i tell you what the
government could do something real
simple you could say you know what uh if
you buy american education bonds you can
collect six percent tax-free who's not
going to buy american education bonds
100 we need to invest
in these kids because those kids are our
future literary and they're saving us
you have got to
cultivate that you've got to make that a
business
education in america is not a business
but yet incarceration is it doesn't work
and you have to invest in a way where
it's it's long-term and it's sustainable
i actually think that we should have
kids in school monday through saturday
from eight a to six p i think most
people on weekends i mean i think that's
i mean i just got dropped off at church
the why and that's how i got in all
kinds of trouble that's exactly right
and i learned very differently than
everyone else so i had to go in extra
time anyway with the teacher and we have
to make sure we feed them breakfast
lunch and dinner because you're not
going to study so well if your stomach's
a little empty so we have to we have to
re-hop no excuse for that we have to
overhaul the whole thing like
literally it is we invest more in the
what i call the twilight years that t
when you're going to retire now we have
trillions invested for the twilight
years right now we got to move some of
those trillions over to the toddler
years and we have to have that balance
it can't just be all the money in the
twilight years you got to have something
watching the movie twilight yeah yeah
you got to have it in the in the toddler
years right so that first d is education
that's everything and obviously that
second e is equal justice and we know
when we don't have it the imbalance you
see the civil unrest everybody loses
everything it's selfish to fight for
this
everybody loses and and the thing is i
always say to america look at how much
you have to lose
you like you have it all
but if it implodes you have nothing it
literally can go up in smoke and that's
scary and shameful so you have to have
that balance and you have to have you
know that equal justice and you have to
show the world this is the proper way to
do it and you know that third e is
economic inclusion
and if you don't have that economic
conclusion you are going to continue to
have that imbalance you're not going to
develop your human resources and your
human capital at a fast enough rate for
america to stay where it should be
and you're going to have crime
you're going to have crime and i think
that a lot of people it seemed to only
get through to them over the pandemic
when it was like if one person is sick
of someone with in a lower income
bracket that you're like not my problem
don't need to worry about this you're
going to get
it almost showed how conte i mean
contagious of viruses that's obvious but
it's all contagious it's all it's you
know it's so funny a friend of mine um
paid a lot of money for a home in bel
air paid like 20 25 million bucks cash
for a home
and one day we were at lunch yes he's
single
[Laughter]
so
one day at lunch
he says to me
you know so
what happened was there was the bel air
fires yes and the bel air fires were you
know triggered by some homelessness
encampment under the scrub right
homeless people trying to stay warm
so the bel air fire gets out of control
and
take out all these homes in bel air now
he's in a 25 million dollar mansion
right paid cash i'm saying he says wow
he goes my fire insurance is 500 000 a
year
he goes before the fire i didn't even
know what it was he said it was a
negligible number it may have been for
him it was a negligible it wasn't that
big of a didn't show up on his radar he
goes but now it's on my radar half a
million a year just fire insurance and
like there's the imbalance why couldn't
that 500 go to away boom it's we're just
it's like the whole thing of um not that
i'm you know against us but like uh the
uh the tollbooth operators the toll it
just pays their that's right at this
point which is fine that the unions will
keep that in place but it's like
basically this you're just paying an
insurance company this five or 2000
could have gone to we're gonna pay it
anyway and by the way someone with a 25
million dollar cash i'm sure they go
i'll do the 24 million dollar one if it
this million if it doesn't burn down if
it doesn't burn down i'd rather have my
24 million one forever than the 25 one
that burns down and more it's 500 grand
a year for just fire insurance
we're just treating symptoms not
witnesses we're not addressing it right
and you have to bring that back like
we're not preventing because we're also
going not my problem that's the next
generation's problem that's the next
generation's problem and you know the
imbalance will cr you'll create a
serious public health issue you keep
having homeless people out there on the
street
and they are living amongst you know
human waste and with rodents you're
going to create
other viruses
and epidemics and pandemics and you're
not going to survive and forget the
emotional toll of can't let my kids
outside i'm too scared to walk it's just
the con this also fear of other humans
who you know this lack of understanding
of addiction is also sort of a giant one
lack of health care there's just so many
like deep
shameful frankly wounds that lead to
this and when it's you know people are
constantly living in fear and if you
think that you have it you know so good
because you're in your car and the
homeless people are there but you're
constantly thinking about it no you're
stressing yourself out you're not
letting your kids just go play at the
playground and don't talk to this person
it's taking such a giant toll i think on
our soul yes to try to ignore
human beings yes you know that are there
no one wants to be homeless that's
exactly right no one wants to be in that
situation and you have to you have to
provide that economic inclusion you have
to provide that balance
um you won't survive it if it's
imbalance you are going to suffer from
it the crime will just be enormous
and we have to make sure we have that
that fourth fee would be environmental
protection
you know we have to
we we're in
the weather channel he knows the
temperatures are going up yeah we're in
a bad place i mean you know we have like
you know close to 400 people with the
weather channel really smart people and
i asked all the scientists
uh because they didn't want
uh they would never talk about climate
change or global warming um because you
know
folks were afraid to offend donald trump
because he was saying no such thing as
climate change or global warming and
what i said i said okay look i said get
all i'll get all my scientists into the
room and i want to talk to him and so i
asked him i said listen up by show a
hand just raise your hands
climate change global warming is it real
are we in trouble is it the greatest
threat to human beings on planet earth
that's all i want to know and without
exception they all raise their hands and
said yes
and i said okay
i am not here i'm not trying to offend
anybody i'm not trying to offend
anyone
all i want is to know the truth and i
just want you to tell them no skin in
the game facts should not be emotional
it's not political it's not emotional
and i know that you have been tiptoeing
and you never wanted to say climate
change global warming and you never
wanted to tell people what to look out
for scientists are going through what
comedians are going through can't say
that word can't say that i can't say
that right comedian signed it so i sit
look
we are here
the weather channel we're here to help
save lives
that's what we do 24 7. we are giving
people essential weather information to
protect themselves their families their
loved ones their worldly possessions and
we have to do that unapologetically
animals are children and yeah you have
to animals as well everybody and i said
just tell them the truth
tell them what you've told me
because it's a mere two degrees hotter
off of the coast of africa it's going to
create record-breaking hurricanes that
will hit america like we have never seen
it hit before just say it say that
climate climate change is real and that
two degrees is going to take out
multi-billion dollar disasters and lives
just be honest and
tell them the truth
and if they hate us for it because we're
not saying the popular statement i you
think i'm you just say i have a beach
house you think i'm happy about this i
have many beach houses i don't want them
to sink
you know yeah so so because all i want
to do is save lives protect lives and
i'm not trying to be political and i
don't want to hurt any i'm not i'm not
trying to be in that and i'm just
telling you i think a lot of people go
i can't solve glaciers but it's because
it's such an overwhelming thing to hear
it's also you know i've been doing a lot
of research because i'm working on this
dog food that's half cricket protein
because the amount of water we use to
make the meat is just it's 260 000
gallons per cow so it's just a giant
like you know drought machine so um i
was i'm talking this guy that works in
water conservation he's like not only
are you gonna have to are we gonna get
to a point where it's gonna be like you
can only take three showers a week you
can only use this much water a day it's
just gonna start getting cut off
basically um but also we got to think
about like bigger things like you know
fertilize that russia provides a lot of
the fertilizer for the world like we
might have a famine coming soon you're
gonna have
all of that and then some and that was
all i said was look as the 100 owner of
the weather channel it let it i'll take
it i'll take the hit
but the one thing we're going to do is
tell
everybody
what you know as brilliant scientists
the truth because i think in the past
when people start science silencing
scientists we're going down a very
dangerous path there it is some like
we're just going to tell
the truth and what people don't
understand is that you know what is that
it's just extreme it's you know climb
it's extreme heat it's extreme cold it's
extreme wet it's extreme wind everything
is extreme and what's going to happen is
it's the greatest threat because we have
over 200 million viruses out there that
don't even have a name
and you don't even want them to get a
name because when they get a name then
things are starting to get really bad
so you have a lot of issues like we
don't even want to know what's going to
happen when you melt all of the glaciers
because there are viruses inside of
those
in those glaciers that we don't even
know if we can share the planet with
and they could be released and you don't
know what you're dealing with there's so
much like
we will start to take out water supplies
food supplies minerals we won't have
enough
to take care of the you know half the
people on this planet and the bottom
half 4 billion 5 billion whatever they
will get wiped out
because we didn't manage climate change
and global warming so that fourth e is
so key because it is the greatest threat
to human beings and then it's going to
cause more and more difference between
classes because only the richest people
are going to be able to absorb the air
conditioning
and the wealth gap is going to get worse
and worse and worse because if you don't
have air conditioning your grandma might
just die that's and then you don't have
enough money to eat real food and you're
eating more you know chemical and you
know produce synthetic food and then
that's creating all kinds of issues so
learn to grow your food learn to grow so
you have to be very
you have to lean in on that and that's
that fourth e and
that 50 is real simple empathy which we
touched on we have to stop acting like
we don't see the food insecure
that we don't see the homeless and we
don't see the mentally ill
and
mental illness is probably the greatest
epidemic in our society why is it so
hard to talk about why is it so it's
it's you know i think it's just it's
just one it's really bizarre you walk
outside you break your leg
and you'll be on a gurney and in a
hospital in less than 20 minutes
you walk outside and you start talking
to yourself you will become the
invisible woman
and you will literally starve to death
in front of a 40 million home
and you're invisible people will just
you will not will look past yep and it
took my i remember i'd always take my
kids to school and i drop them off and
because it's my time with them and to
have my conversation with them and find
out how the day before and whatever it
is what are you thinking about today so
do the reset when i love taking my kids
to school and at this point i had only
had one going to school and chloe and
she was two years old maybe and
and she was sitting in the back of the
car and we were driving from home to
school
and she kept saying daddy i see a
homeless person
daddy i see another homeless person
daddy i see another homeless person and
then she said daddy why aren't we
stopping to help them
and i started crying
i started crying because i was like what
is it about me that i turned off that
empathy button
and this little two-year-old girl turned
it back on and i said you're right
you're right it's amazing what we can
normalize which you normalize like
that's not normal like you like you know
if you saw a dog on the street you'd
pull over like and by the way we have
more animal shelters than human shelters
correct i mean like
like it's like so what happens is that
we're not saying to ourselves
look it's like saying to a human being
you're never if you're a baby you're
never going to get a cold
you're never going to get the flu you're
never going to get a pimple or a rash
that's like saying you're never going to
have a mental
challenge
you're never going to hit a mental speed
bump you're going to have a mental
challenge we have inherited a lot of
this you know we have my ancestors
wherever learn your ancestry what you
come from the epigenetic imprinting of
like you know addiction and addiction is
not a choice like and depression and
honor we go oh well he must be an
asshole if he's homeless well he must be
a piece of traffic you don't know his
dad might have been in a war and his dad
before that might have been pressure
prohibition and holocaust that's exactly
right we are the first generation that
is he even has the even the most a
modicum of understanding about
neuroscience and addiction that's
exactly what we will look back and we
will uh it will be a disgrace it would
be a disgrace and you have to say you
know you don't you know like just you
know the ills the evils of slavery and
how do you break 300 years of that
you're gonna have issues
and you have to address it
and we don't address it
and we're seeing it in you know school
shootings and we're seeing it in people
speeding down the street and stabbing
and murdering people like there are way
too many episodes of somebody murdering
somebody and trying to get away with it
but at the end of the day at the top of
the news every day that's a mental
health breakdown and it's an epidemic
that we're not addressing and should it
be taught something be like meditation
taught in schools and mental health
classes you know should understand it
and recognize it and accept it and
address it
understand it is mental health recognize
it and address it and don't just write
it off as they're crazy don't just write
it off as something's wrong with them
you know that's right
they need help i look i remember being
in detroit in in the and you know there
was a it was a big drug problem it was
so bad the
guy next door the kid next door
literally came off his porch
walked in front of my grandmother's
house
walked up the driveway stood on my
grandmother and grandfather's car
he was a drug addict yeah and he and he
started taking their air conditioner out
of the window
okay like just wiggling out of the wind
like it's like we see you
we know you
and uh
we're just gonna watch you take the air
conditioner back to your house like
you're next door
so i mean it's just like you know like
and my grandmother was like that boy
ain't right that boy ain't right yeah
you're right like he needs help they
need help and it's not and it's really
understanding the neuroscience of these
are people that don't hold dopamine
receptors the same way and a lot of
these people i just see so much wasted
talent as well because a lot of people
that you know have addiction problems
that have been have come from um
tremendously complicated backgrounds
they're usually incredibly empathic and
sensitive people where the world is just
harder for them because they're more
sensitive they haven't had the
opportunity to build up the coping
mechanisms drugs were introduced not
because they wanted them to be that did
you know something
bad happened that was not their fault
that's right and then so to me when you
know addicts get sober when people
rehabilitate and you know they're some
of the best people in the world to
either be friends with to work with to
hire right you know and to me i just
always feel lucky because i have a very
addictive personality i just got lucky
that my drug was work that's right and i
could have very had i put this brain
right towards heroin i'd be the best
drug addict on the planet and done and i
know that i just got lucky with the i
just had a good drug that's right and i
i have an addictive personality and i
recognized that i had i have an
addictive personality and i was
fortunate to recognize it early on and
put in a positive direction and what i
said is okay
i'm not gonna smoke i never started
smoking i'm not going to do drugs i
never started doing drugs i'm not going
to drink alcohol i never started
drinking i will be the byron island of
drinking
i will win
right and so i said i'm not going to
start anything other people were trying
to quit
and i recognized that about myself early
on and i wouldn't start
and i said i'm going since i know i have
this addictive personality
i'm going to use it in a positive way
and i'm going to make sure i'm addicted
to things that are positive and you can
only excel but i was fortunate enough to
recognize it and manage it and harness
it and use it to my benefit
and i just stepped away from the things
that would trip me up and you have to
just
you have to help people get there
because you want people to be their best
if they are their best that's the person
who's going to come up with that
cure for the disease that that may take
us out that's the person who's going to
come up with that treatment for that
epidemic that pandemic from that virus
that's being triggered because we
ignored people living out on the streets
and the viruses that they created
because of that it it's it's like it you
have to address it you have to put you
have to right now people are positioned
to fail we're crushing people
and that's why comedy is so needed
because we are crushing people we have
to position people to succeed and to be
their best when you think about last
year over a hundred thousand people died
from fentanyl
that was 9 11 that's 9 11 30 times
not like like it's over a hundred
thousand people you know who are you
know they were positioned to be murdered
it's incredible like i was seeing this
the other reading this the other day
they're doing fentanyl testing strips
for cocaine so now you go to a party and
you're like i test my cocaine to see
i've never done cocaine i guess now we
never get to do it because you know that
ship sale because now you just and then
i was like maybe
you know this is something that had to
get so bad so this next generation like
i see young people not wanting to do
drugs because it's not cool because
their parents did it like my dad smokes
weed i'm gonna smoke weed that's lame
like i wonder if this is going to cause
a bigger swing i mean i just hope that
people go oh drugs you just die if you
do them well they're not fun anymore
right but what's happening is that
you're finding out about all the closet
closeted addicts
and they're dying
and that's that you know that's what's
coming out and it's just another symptom
of how great this mental health
deterioration and why do they feel so
hopeless in the first place why have we
given them nothing to live for or look
forward to we're crushing it if you
don't have a 401k in this country yeah
i'll have a fentanyl yeah we're crushing
people and we have to stop crushing
people we have to position people to
succeed and be their best and if you
actually do that it's going to be much
stronger for the country the world i
mean you can literally have a slice of
heaven right here on earth and you know
what i always like to say is like
charity work is great we all work in
charity we all we shouldn't need this
many charities no you shouldn't i know
we get a little distracted with like oh
this uh charity for homeless people
there's oh this charity for this charity
for addiction i'm like
charities shouldn't have to step in this
much on everything and i know
absolutely not and and i and you don't
even want to come out of the charity
bucket we're very generous nation i
think we donate a little over a hundred
billion a year but if you're in that
business bucket it's about a 80 trillion
dollar bucket you know so that's why
i've always said you know in terms of
donating to educate kids that's great
but we should be funding it
out of that business bucket yep that
bucket where it's like i rather invest
and and have you know get tax-free
interest on an american education bond i
rather invest and structure it where you
know we are educating children and you
get a return
you can make a business out of that it
can be it shouldn't be non-profit it
should be for profit and if you do that
we're going to get a better result i
mean look i think we should pay
a lot more to teachers but we should
also have an incentive program just like
in business if your sales are this then
great if our test scores are yes with
these kids can i give you a 200 000
bonus because you got our test scores
because we need the you got to test our
test scores higher we need the
intellectual capital we need it to
compete globally you know 50 60 years
ago you could play the game this way
where you would half the people are
engaged in the other half or
disenfranchised but now we have global
competition now we need everybody on
deck and everybody positioned to bring
their a game
and if you give everybody an opportunity
to succeed and bring their a game we're
better because of it
we can no longer afford
you know failure and bottom line is if
you are educated and if you're engaged
you are an american asset
and if you're not educated and you're
not engaged then you're a liability and
we can now no longer fund the liability
of you not being the best you can be
because the global competition is
crushing us and we're crushing you and
we have to bring balance to the system
so we all succeed because the system
isn't working the way it is now does it
feel like we're we just hit like a
breaking point you i mean listen i mean
you watched it you saw this civil unrest
you know in you know in the summer of 20
you're seeing the homelessness you're
seeing
epic epidemics kick in and pandemics
you're seeing the imbalance you're
seeing the food insecurity you're seeing
the incarceration it's like these are
all you know things should be getting
better technically and there's a way to
eliminate you have to lean in and you
have to address it holistically and
you're not gonna get there and then and
then gonna try and say like everything's
okay i'm gonna shut the narrative down
hey comedians shut up hey athletes shut
up yup hey hey i don't like the way you
do your newscast shut up everything is
just shut up and shut down and just
listen to me and let me tell you
your truth
your truth
never give up your truth do you don't
you know don't let somebody say what
you're going to believe you're lying
eyes
you're going to believe your lying ears
you're like just keep hold on to your
truth but i'm going to say what everyone
is thinking right now going why doesn't
this guy run for office i'm not bringing
it up
but
do what what do we do with the fact that
now no one's sane will run for office
because of the process the the type of
people that should be running for office
i feel like now because of the circus
that it's become you kind of have to be
yeah you know listen i think
yeah controversial yeah politicians you
know listen they're nothing more than
temporary hired help
i love that quote of yours so much and
and and we we have to take it back as
people
the power sits with the people you work
for us you work for us
and i believe you don't need to be
president you just need to be a person
and say listen buster you work for us
and let me tell you what you need to do
today this week this month it's about
the people it's not about you we have to
be clear about what we want and we have
to be clear about the timetable in which
they achieve it you have to run them
like a business and you have to be
really clear like oh you want to be
present not a problem here's what i need
here are the 10 things i need by the end
of next week jump to it
and
i have more
i have more influence by being outspoken
and by being outside of the system
and i'm able to use media to be loud and
proud about it and say you need to do
better here this is unacceptable this is
why i've built this media company this
is how we challenge authority and checks
and balances that's checks and balances
pressure you put i'm here to tell the
world you need to look why did i buy the
griot
the griot used to be owned by nbc i
bought the griot because i said okay
there are a lot of people working to
suppress the black vote
and so i said okay i'ma buy the grill
which is the number one news and
information site for black america right
according to comscore but i bought it to
say the reason why people are out there
trying to crush your vote is because you
are the most powerful vote the white
vote is split 50 50. you're the deciding
vote
and they know that so when you show up
you get president barack hussein obama
when you don't show up anybody can walk
into the white house so this is why they
do it by the numbers they look at your
zip code they know what you make thirty
thousand forty thousand a year so they
close all the polling places they make
you take a one hour drive when you get
there you stand in line for a week day
right on a week it's not a weekday on a
weekday seven hours a week and then they
put you back on the road
it's an eight-hour day do you feel like
by the way just really to make should we
all only be screaming about changing the
voting day to a weekend well so what i
said what i said is you know when you go
to the griot i said i told our editor i
said i want it at the site black america
must vote
and you can't vote like you're white you
have to vote like you're black i live in
a rich white neighborhood when i go to
vote they valet park my car and they
offer me you know a cappuccino
and like and i'm back in the car in 10
minutes they're facing i'm gonna come
back and then you know if you if you
takes longer than 20 minutes to vote
you're gonna have people like what the
hell's going on over here right now so i
said you are positioned to fail so what
they're saying is we know you can't
afford to take the day off to vote so i
said okay you can't vote like you're
white you got to vote like your black so
you need to start working overtime so
you can put away the money to take that
day off
tell your employer i'm not coming in on
that tuesday and you vote people died
for us to vote your vote is powerful and
we as people everybody all americans
need to be clear and say
we deserve better and because we do
deserve better you should never think
about your mental health you should
hitting rock bottom you should never
think about crime and your health care
you should never think about food like
it should just it's your birthright it's
your birthright that if you have a
medical issue
you're going to get the best medical
attention i don't care if you make two
dollars an hour or two million an hour
there's certain things that are just
you're human you deserve it and we have
the right as human beings as americans
to say that and to be loud and say look
stop with the high school popularity
contest it's not about you it's about us
what you're going to do for us what
you're going to do to make our lives
better you need to really step in and
and then you get all this filibuster
stuff and blah blah blah
we have more influence because we can
donate money to people who really carry
out the agenda and we can vote for
people who really carry out the agenda
we just have to be clear about the
agenda i'm clear about my agenda you
have to hey politicians and they come to
me for money and i sit with them
you know i was on you know i was on the
phone with nancy pelosi for an hour
and i'm like hey nancy this is what i
want
money is easy
we have plenty of money
and i but here's what i want
it's about education it's about economic
inclusion it's about environmental
protection like don't want to talk about
it got to achieve it she's there she's
leaning in she wants to do it but that's
my conversation
and anybody can have that with their
local representative
and you got to have that conversation
and be clear you have to deliver this
for me
no ifs hands or butts and by the way
i'm not giving you a second term if you
don't get it done right you have a job
hit your goals hit your timetable hit
your mark
because
we're dying at literally dying out here
and i think you know for me
that's why i love what i
you know what i do i'm able to be in
comedy
be unfiltered speak my truth tell people
what i think what i feel if they care
uh build a media company that's able to
speak to millions and millions of people
say to people you may want to think
about it like this don't release your
power
step up i don't care who you vote ask
questions ask questions i really don't
care who you vote for i just want you to
be a part of the process make it a habit
i would just like to go on record saying
i'm very proud of my choice in heroes
i feel like i have impeccable taste in
heroes i just i have been waiting for
this for so long
and i wanted to wait to have you on
until we were like a very well-oiled
machine and this is uh you know our
150-somethings
episode and i've been dreaming about
this i've been looking forward to this
um
and uh i love you and i would not have
the career that i have if it wasn't for
you um and i just can never thank you
enough and i hope you'll come back and
um
absolutely i'll come back you know how
much i love you you know that i mean
that's easy i mean you are you're truly
amazing and i'm so proud of you you are
really spectacular so i mean when i met
you i had like seven dollars
is that right
you should have told me that i would
have borrowed 500
i would have left you with two
you know i couldn't leave that joke
there
you put that joke on the table come on i
couldn't leave i had to pick that joke
up and throw it back at you and you had
seven dollars i didn't know that seven
dollars yep i was in like 40 grand of
debt as well but that was is that right
another story for another day in college
yeah yeah that's all good stuff
that's all i was eating uh turkey jerky
from pink dot on sunset
i would buy one for the whole day
because it would last you kind of for
the whole day yeah i would put maple
syrup on it because someone told me it
had all the minerals you needed maple
syrup and um i had three teeth i needed
to get replaced like you you know you
you changed my life oh wow and you gave
more female comedians and comedians of
color tv spots uh than anyone and i
think in history oh listen you know i i
love i love what i do and i love people
and i just want to see the best
uh for people and i just want people to
just really live their dreams and be
happy and that's it people would say to
me all the time people would be like
well there's no female comedians i'm
like uh byron allen and eric managed to
find about 200 of them oh yeah i always
said it i said on comics unleash there's
one on every episode so they found them
that's exactly there's no female comics
and i and i said and i said we won't do
the show without a female comic and i
said you know i think we did one episode
and it wasn't a female because she
dropped out or something i said i hate
the energy
uh the guys when it's just me and four
guys it just becomes like a frat house
and i said you know i don't like it i
just want that balance and i want to
amplify and celebrate and position
people to succeed that's my whole thing
that's what i but i'm so proud of you
you are amazing i watch your career it's
unbelievable like your strength like
you're a real superstar you're a real
superstar and you're a real gift we're
lucky to have you we really are lucky to
have you you need to know that i i it's
very rare that i'm speechless but i just
i i cannot put into words how grateful i
am uh that you exist thank god you exist
and um
every time you talk i think the world
gets better oh thank you thank you for
having me you know how much i love you i
actually got on two freeways yeah i
don't think i've done that for anybody
gotten on two freeways i might get on
one but two oh my god i was like 405 and
the 101 where the hell is she lit white
women are very sure
what can i say i was like okay so you're
that's yeah that's serious love if i get
on two freeways okay i just want you to
know that i love you so much i i do want
you to get home to your daughters
because otherwise they'll become
comedians exactly i want you to go and
be present for your children yeah i
gotta go get hang out with the wife and
kids make sure they don't become commute
but that's a good thing too thank you
for i love you i end these very
awkwardly and as always don't ride
elephants
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]